was super fun um and of course a little
game called space plan now listen space
plans very it's it's dividing people all
right it's just a game where you tap on
the screen and you make energy out of
potatoes and it's fun all right I love
it
I'm just gonna say it people are
laughing at me I don't care I don't care
I love space plan and I'm gonna spread
the word about space plan not with this
though because the the cameras are not
know how to turn off we're gonna play
some space play later a lot of special
guests coming up we have some exclusive
music performances a little bit later on
in the night we haven't even delved into
these costumes over here I've only
pulled out the fake bat once and hit
myself with it so there's gonna be a
beating later so tune in for that for
sure thank you for watching it oh good
night Eureka good night thank you for
watching us twitch YouTube and Facebook
how's everybody doing Katie Lu shields
who invited me over to her house earlier
and I think she only did that because
she knew I was gonna be here for 24
hours so well played Katie Lu shields
well played a little miss of otaku Chloe
was here earlier and I have the bruises
to prove it and he will be back later on
so keep watching he's also checking in
with us every hour which is super fun
and right now your stream is not dying
we're doing a little thing we like to
call cycling the stream because we're
doing it for 24 hours and and these
platforms are not made just read for 24
hours but we want to give you as much
streaming as possible which is exciting
so one thing we haven't done any of yet
is I don't think we've played a single
sports game and you know we gotta get to
the sports games because Google Play is
full of amazing sports games and I'm not
really a fan of sports game so I'm gonna
bring in some people who are a fan of
sports games but there's gonna be three
of them which means we have to move the
giant head I need to go put on a new
shirt so let's see let's please welcome
oh my god
I don't even know who's coming up next
Lee this this is crazy this is what
we're dealing with right here it's eight
hours of sheet everybody it's eight
hours of sheet let's bring in some Conan
staffers Jenn Alyssa and Beth morass
everybody giving my hand no man no I'm
not go you guys sit here I'm gonna get
out of the way yeah I'm just gonna take
your cue ball can somebody hold this
here just don't put it on your head
okay cool all right I'll get you guys
set up as you guys sit down here say
hello to the stream I love you know I
need to kind of grab it by the hair this
is by the way also the way if you ever
see Conan need to pull him up off the
ground grab him by the hair that's what
his doctors recommend highly well cut to
the full shot right there for the ladies
now introduce yourselves tell them what
you do on the show hi I'm Jen I'm a
segment associate so I hope with the
guest segments and the interviews on the
show I am ELISA and I am a clip
researcher I'm Beth you all know me from
the chat real job also okay cuz that's
all I do
don't cut down other people's work all
right you guys are gonna start off
playing a little FIFA soccer you go
first okay all right you're trained what
version is this do I get to choose like
what team I'm playing I've never played
it so good luck I'm ready for Jenn does
this look great short I just click
whatever button looks the most fun oh
it's downloading oh how many comments
going or are we interesting people yeah
there by swiping towards the goal okay
it's have to continue sure is what do
you mean made me thank you
but we should tell us in fact how we
also oh yeah we um I guess why we are
all doing this together is we're also
roommates yeah yeah because working
together is not enough no no no we need
to be with each other we have to hang
out always yeah all night absolutely
absolutely
and our cat committee here unfortunately
yeah had to have surgery the other day
so Center your well wishes super the cat
to get the cat YouTube and then twitch
and then yeah I just a some caffeine
everyone needs to caffeine up or you
know uh yeah yeah you got me included
yeah but this isn't coffee um
this game is just wow just grapes know
there's a way to get to the main menu
but I'm not sure how yeah of course of
course
oh okay I got five out of five goals on
easy difficulty alright we're ready to
finally play okay yeah yeah great
shooting now let's start although I
don't know though yes it is Ronaldo how
what are your feelings towards Ronaldo
you know I don't find him as attractive
as most people I wasn't even was just
going as a soccer he's fine he's fine
I'm more of a messy fan myself
sure I would say what about you bad you
love sports yeah
to go to bars when you guys watch it
yeah you go for the alcohol yeah you
know we're all Tottenham Hotspur fans
I make them which what exactly is a
hospice I don't know I heard that it's
from like a Shakespeare play that's kind
of like what got me into it you know
Shakespeare sorry I saw one comment that
said good friends don't always make good
roommate these guys I can vouch are good
friends and great roommates so Jen I can
say that Jen is a good friend and yeah I
mean if there's a better game with [ __ ]
you can play like space team or don't
even joke about space time you know I
love that I don't know away with my
heart I don't know why are you guys are
gonna instead are gonna play a little
game called Alto which is a snowboarding
game does anybody here snowboard I do
okay perfect
it's gonna be great sorry Altos
adventure order you're going for it here
we go
let's just make sure yeah gonna do is
oh it's beautiful
there's alpacas alpacas are llamas I'm
going all pakka
okay long as are escaping down the
mountain quick oh this is so high stakes
[Music]
oh sure
oh this is fun this reminds me of a game
I used to play my gender this is a 1080
but this is not 1080 but it's pretty
great I like that there's crows okay and
just the Olympics just happened so I'm
still in that mines oh yeah
Jenna's on the Olympic hi Jen please
tell everyone what you spent most of
your time doing during watching I went
so far as to take a curling class yes I
also recommend everyone busy they're
like get everyone wet now yes curling
has experienced quite a surge as of late
and understandably so it's riveting and
he wants to game yeah see I wasn't
thinking in the best thank you waffle
tarts it is the best waffle I'm very
concerned about you jumping on this
slope that doesn't seem very good it's
bad for you but you know what I think I
got on my old hat or llamas I don't
understand
oh that's a broken neck oh oh would you
get to keep going that's not realistic
it sure is um tap and hold the backflip
oh here we go hear that there it is the
longer your scarf will grow like the
doctor oh there's no well did you catch
that when you kind of went over it oh I
just grind on this rope going slow oh
okay oh there's one there's one there's
one get it Jenny yes oh look how long my
scarf is getting oh I don't like that
sign either
don't worry avoided it why did you cast
it make sure you have enough speed and
oh oh oh we're not gonna have enough
speed Oh barely barely Jen okay now it's
we're ready to start our own adventure
whoa like Ellen when you're in like the
doctor's office and you're scared
no let me show you want to give a shout
no I have never had music play what I'm
getting a shot I have music
this game is called El Alto Alto Thank
You someone said you got this [ __ ] thank
you for the I really appreciate it at
that opening up at that one I wish I was
a girl in the middle drinking mine mixed
drink yes yes she's the smart one Altos
adventure that's what it's called Alka
thank you
okay let's say your turn let's use white
mice question or that doesn't played
anything so you have to beat 4338
if she can we'll see all right Jenn Jenn
is just a master of video games so
please okay someone watched a hundred
hours of footage from the Olympics I did
too
yeah Jen definitely did that
so Jun but what are my controls here oh
okay oh I didn't see a rock death is the
sober person yeah except for that can
you tell us your feelings about you know
just life yeah fact about Jen she earned
not Jen I'm just very distracted right
now about that that she loves the moon
yeah the moon is great I love the moon -
big big through the moon I'd say that's
uh
waning just by the waning gibbous no no
that's wrong i I don't I know nothing
about the main phases but I like them
looking at it I took a star class in
college oh really
I almost lost it there can I like hold
it down go faster Wow jump over two
rocks in one run I mean good try
Thank You Jen very supportive
[Music]
oh you have to beat the level yeah and
I'll get there eventually I'm just
learning on the pool I'm not a natural
at video games like giant please keep me
humble but for those just joining this
is Jen Alyssa and I'm Beth and we work
here at Conan and now we're playing this
game yeah we're not gonna pay extra
we all intern together way back when yes
do you have any question was five or six
years ago there's a very long toes and
here we are now yeah it was definitely
fun we all were lucky enough to get
hired yep how are you great just gotta
jump on the roof I did I thought yeah
we're all roommates to blue lafon
together and we have a cat and it's all
great
you know like Three's Company suka you
know ate something and had to have
surgery like a big old jerk it's
riveting conversation that's all I have
to talk about it sounds and I like this
game better than the soccer game I agree
me too we couldn't get it started yeah
ocker game I blame Ronaldo to be honest
oh I do too oh what's that magnet
no I didn't I'm very focused on getting
over to rocks so I can beat this level
we do have a lot more obstacles than I
yes yes I do
Tapan will to do a backflip oh that's
ultraviolet says oh okay
so thank you thank you thank you I will
do that I didn't get to oh I did get the
two rocks again okay okay Jen you're the
master of this please wait uh should we
get our charcuterie plate
yeah we're nursing something yeah yeah
[Music]
I need snacks whenever I get my needs
name yeah
snacks are key when candy look at this
so what we have here see this is a
leftovers from our Oscar party yes yes
yes that we're now going to eat here
live on camera we're gonna eat this
leave it right here on this clean dragon
yep what do you want there's a little
storm coming in oh but it's raining yes
oh yeah
[Music]
okay since you're not eating it and you
said you're hungry
I'm just gonna put this I'm in the zone
look how long like scarf scanning yes
just you know brag about and how great
your scarf is and mine was awful
[Music]
oh yes there is okay oh we have props so
let's
backflip I want to use that construction
we have twice
damage out of it hey someone help me
yeah this game is awesome I've never
played it before and I have to say I'm
having a really fun time with it whoo my
scarf is yellow yes please let's get in
the spirit here okay
and run back okay this especially for
you it's a glove ooh I like it
what else do we got oh one glove
[Music]
actually pretty hot
I like my one okay great great thanks
anybody tape I'm very cozy and
comfortable right now thank you great
great great
now all this cold weather in LA we've
been having this brisk 60 degrees it is
don't joke around
yeah because there's East Coast is
having events
look at me get all those llamas yeah
yeah yeah okay you can do it I believe
in you when you live in well I know
oh here we go Oh No Oh weird the way was
supposed to go years ago you got too
cocky
like Matt Rebecca Hamilton better that's
really tough tough Olympic curlers I can
give you my master
Hamilton our Olympic curlers that's
really tough I think I like back up
better back up for sure Becca also looks
like um Karen Cole Gareth which from my
favorite murder which always just brings
me a lot of joy here right yeah they do
give you a turn usually a much better at
sharing that's here you go here we go
here don't go someone said this is a
very relaxing game but yeah yeah I need
the Hat for thank you so much okay here
we go
[Music]
oh wait well if someone just has to be
like Matt Rebecca Hamilton or the
musical Hamilton better Oh Hamilton the
musical we've all seen it jet off yeah
Jen and I are when rocket in your pocket
that's what it's a curling term it's not
it's a curling trip that's doesn't seem
it's you at the curling term we nano
wait what were some more curling tubes
cuz I've heard think I feel like I've
heard other Karly terms in there like
they don't sound out like athletic terms
there's the Hat you think that's what
it's cold oh god I'm not getting dates
right but in order to incensing throwing
the rock you deliver the stone that's
the best way that's beautiful it's a
curling video game Jen it's your life
calling it's what you were born to look
at I think I should study I don't like
to do things that I'm not good at I
don't know the thrower delivers the
stone yes that's correct
just have that that makes sense it is
it's so soon I can't say that I feel
like this when I snowboard the few times
that I do snow
we went snowboarding together we did and
it was really fun
it was very fun but you were much more
daring than I was
you know no you you went you went on a
you went on a and we went above the
bunnies we're not one big bear beep
there were 42 powers awesome la yep
we're big fans of Big Bear I'm a really
great restaurant up there a really good
pancakes
yes if yes if you ever want to go
snowboarding and you're in Southern
California you're inviting them to your
no no Jen isn't your planet Earth
together in a group getting their beefy
okay look I need a backflip Thank You
Jen I keep on saying I'll pack up it's a
llama
[Music]
I feel like I'm in the Andes and that's
why I'm sitting at home Kaka
it does have that vibe
[Music]
Wow
okay you ready for the Hat okay I can't
see Oh Jen did you want some message
after a long time on the mountain Jen
what is your favorite yeah but it's not
that hard um what's your favorite food
snowboarding macaroni and cheese my
favorite oh it's so good it is you're
doing you're doing gonna be a sad who
left their gum yes look your scarf is
gonna get so long you were good at this
the whole time you were dying that two
flavors she's just humble we don't call
her
but that's good though okay I need to
start looking at these comments
downloads on it sure it does it's
obviously never leaving I have something
to say about it
know what sometimes I keep the 20 no you
be my squirt oh man
it's like watching a non-korean yeah we
should put that on eBay that would
salford be charity yeah yeah what what
much charity should we should we sell
that come to seems like you would yeah
that they're doing great
um oh I support Spurs because you know I
just did some research and came across
them and loved them ever since
wait this is ambassador no we're so hot
no more Hotspur
no oh oh sorry turn wait oh yes the Hat
the Hat of course you're late what is a
little girl in Despicable Me who always
wears the beanie like over it's like
it's so fluffy I'm gonna know a
different one a different one the one
mental child oh yeah the angsty one I
feel like they all have a little bit of
angst
[Music]
right alright so we have to land three
black oh I'm never that'll sit it never
never Chelsea three backflips is the
goal here so that is a workaholic yeah
she can all that yeah absolutely that's
great work ethic if I get a chance to
watch the match I definitely will let
match I Tottenham I honestly I couldn't
tell you who they're playing tonight
call yourself a fan I know I'm the worst
I usually just like I'm at work and see
on Twitter that they're playing and I'm
like oh great and I turn it on TV but
wait I knew I needed to go on the real
are you going to twitch combat I don't
believe I'm sorry you guys are telling
me terrible dis game says Chad yep yep
no way oh that's your arm Ventus that's
right yet pick up a hot hover feather
what
I don't know anyone know what a feel
there's one person they were looking
forward to this era when they heard was
about sports but this is good what's
good oh it's good oh man it was having
it all that's a great time
lyrics need to find the hover feather
we're also feeling very honored that we
are the opening act for Oscar winner
trappin Yamamoto oh yeah coming on after
this with the equally wonderful Diane
yeah if you guys didn't watch Conan last
night I don't know what you're doing but
yeah here's a link to what we're talking
about the the English Premier League is
it's getting better in my opinion
okay rate corndogs one to ten uh
three Disneyland corndogs are a solid
9.2 guys I mean know this rate they're
going great are the best okay I really
just want to get it back with it they're
not gonna meet Alto yes we are shoot I
got to I got to risk yes you I got too
cocky with it here you try to do someone
just has to we all have the same job
title Jen please please explain no we
don't but we work fullest and I work
closely together we both work on the
guest segment she does all the clip
aspects of it and I researched the
guests that come on could maybe find
conversation topics and stuff like that
and just kind of prep for the interview
so sort of the same but
different departments titanum yes yeah
yeah it's fun and I did another but all
I was about I got cocky I said I did
another backflip - that's what happened
to me - okay I'm gonna do another run
yeah because that one was really yeah
I'm sorry it's really hard it's like a
book
what does it play play pass it wasn't
this game is a lot harder than it looks
it's better boss if if we worked in the
same world she probably
[Music]
what type of sources processes to use
research we use basically Google what
we're playing right now baby we use a
lot of Google shout and then we also be
used a few different online databases
social media stuff like that all that
stuff to find interesting things to talk
about Jen you see the is that Anna
Kendrick on the moment I do get that I
look like Anna Kendrick sometimes yes
she does and someone said they love to
god was it I don't know
Mario Mario thank you thank you thank
you for loving to God chica has a fan
club oh my gosh if you guys start a fan
club for - good boy oh boy
ah no have we been on this level for
like 40 minutes at cleaning up at home
after themselves
I think me yeah we're all doing a lot
amazing yes chuka chuka exactly - cos
very bad cleanup efforts
okay well death is married to the best
[Music]
really wanna lay aside him if he don't
hear probably napping or know who is the
best cook oh man probably bad bath yeah
she's the one who's she is the one who
really has recently gotten into cooking
especially with sausage yes and she also
sometimes gets an inspiration to become
a mixologist okay which I always
appreciate because she has us as her
guinea pigs
yes oh yeah she doesn't eat great rates
making the impeachment yes that was a
great way to get Beth what's your best
sausage recipe oh it has to be the one
that's like you got some tiny potatoes
in there you've got some shallots some
arugula that you drizzle with some lemon
it's very simple recipe this is like not
based stuff check it out it's good
sounds great you should have your own
cooking show yeah yeah um oh I'm looking
forward to a betting show and it'll all
be saucy it already thinking that you
can just put in the oven is it like I'm
channeling my inner Chloe Kim oh nope
knowing that work she's better where
that she's better though he can run
what's your bottom in this mountain so
far I don't think I don't think so where
they are I couldn't tell you
Mountain that never ends so is there any
chance of us getting space team owned or
we just gonna have to wait until the
next 24 hour livestream I think it would
be tricky because it would be one set up
we only have one stream that's that's
understandable I never know about the
Y's I should try people again but I just
get nervous and I'm very soothed by this
game oh man I died again C soothing I
find death very soothing oh yeah
fun fact this game is very relaxing and
I guess you know what it's like a late
it's later in the night people are you
know just like she's been relaxing oh
man Chen I was distracted by your
beautiful speech they are giving tonight
and I died again okay one more time and
then it's going back to bed Roger best
turn again
Oh Weezy don't land three backflips oh
that's oh that's that's the goal
okay I wasn't paying attention to the
pole which seems hard and we have to get
the hover feather which I still what is
this hover feather I haven't seen any
feathers both hovering and not so I
don't know what it's talking about
oh but this for escape I think is a bit
new um what's your favorite form of
hovering Jen I don't know
[Music]
do you like a good hover boat a good
word all I'm Marty McFly in Back to the
Future 2 I believe you know oh I got a
magnet I don't know what is the
magnitude I thought I'd jump over the
house I didn't have to do it what 1080
reverse melon that's it okay okay yeah
yeah you got it you got it just yeah
with that out real fast yeah yeah oh
whoa I was on ice and I went really fast
I liked it no oh it was so cool and it
attracts coins that's oh okay thank you
that doesn't seem like it great thank
you John green grass Gingras feet okay
you know what I almost landed a backflip
would you rather be the best
supervillain or a mediocre superhero a
mediocre superhero
no thank you well as your superpower if
you could have anything I always go with
Barack Obama's answer of being able to
speak every language no that's actually
a really good one I like that that's fun
I like I never went with that until I
heard that and I was like oh man I can
never beat that that's a good one
I like how about you I I don't know if
that's no mediocre though but anyways
please well no it doesn't it to be
mediocre I'm just saying like in general
like if you could have um
I think okay you can do backflips
whenever you come to a steep dropoff
jump and do a backflip off stop how do
we jump you hold it down you hold it um
my superhero power I think I would like
telekinesis because then it's like a
two-for-one sure that I could also fly
because I could move myself with my mind
I don't know what I mean like yeah you
have flight and but how far can your
telekinesis I'm not lucky to go over
like I'm not gonna fly like overseas
okay I was just gonna flip maybe like
fly to the grocery store like it's
simple quite sure sure I mean superhero
power or villain if you would go now I
feel like my answer makes me a villain I
feel like I would have the power to
mimic other powers and then I just see
powers in the world of real anguish I'm
gonna skip that Wow but I don't want to
steal it from the blood I just want to
skip have it pick a hover feather what I
made the executive decision so we're
going with it so now we just need to lay
on three backflips but if we don't I say
we skip that too and that way we can go
to a new level
okay okay I like I like this idea I
broke I guess that's true she like gives
words sure yeah yeah yeah yeah uh miss
Skylar confirmed no not in a smaller way
where's my hero fan this guy oh my gosh
I would save the cheerleader save the
world
that sure was so good and so scary but
I'm also and I get scared really easily
okay I'm gonna land a backflip guys just
you wait
oh I am so oh oh oh oh did you have to
swirl your finger to land a backflip
yeah you did great
yeah you swirl it I thought you said you
just hold it down I swear swirl oh and
the rock got me oh he's got a limb too
but now you now you know how okay we got
it
do you eat my video games often um every
once in a while we have a ps4 Beth know
my destiny too and I just got a Game Boy
Color oh yeah yeah
you don't swirl I did swirl and it
worked though he said he to her she said
you don't have to swirl I don't know who
it was because I can't read the comments
right now I'm very busy
um yeah we play um ps4 Jen and I had an
epic draw in FIFA 18 the other night it
was zero zeros and I played battle stars
battle friends yeah every once in a
while I like that one
and Crash Bandicoot my gender game it's
Jen's favorite she has a crush bad that
Beth got her Christmas yeah oh no crash
bandicoot such a great throwback it was
and the updated the one reactant is
great for ps4 so that I made I made a
wrong decision I mean I'm gonna go one
more time and then I'll pass it back to
Beth or Jenn okay okay it's sometimes I
find it easier to look straight ahead
okay okay but I feel like you're trying
to throw me off by saying that
I don't know if I trust you I don't
trust you I don't trust you generally
nope I think I think that you secretly
wanted to be the supervillain I know
okay no because there's a big gap I
can't you're right right okay me if you
like games like crash you would like
mystic man we'll go back and check it
later it really can't we haven't played
it in a while
Chrissy cuz I'm stuck on a level Christy
I know her yeah all our fans are just
our friends yep how many of you are
pseudonyms yeah if you know us raise
your hand allege the business view well
this is my question what was the first
game console we played n64 for me it was
Sega Genesis I had a Sega Genesis and my
favorite game was Ecco the Dolphin you
just like swim around as a dolphin and
make like sonar noises how many flips
did you get should we just skip it
no we did it you've got a three back
foot no you only have to do three
backflips total it took us that long to
do three - but it is your turn okay okay
I know it was a good game someone says
echo is break a battery mud buy us crash
is great you don't you don't have to pay
everyone it for three seconds I can do
that if I had telekinesis
oh I don't watch The Bachelor Christy
you know this we're not a bachelor house
we're not I mean if you want separate
look yes I want to be the season did you
did everyone give final jeopardy right
tonight I got it right
what was it I don't remember the
question but I remember that yes sir
who's the answer then we can maybe track
back and figure out the question um well
the answer was ever
like the book yes that the category was
British novels oh man the rocks that
keep sneaking up I know they come out of
nowhere I it's getting harder I don't
know I want to say yes jump over five
rocks so I should be able to do that
okay
eyes on the prize here I go it's go tank
jeopardy is better than The Bachelor you
are correct but also like it's fine to
watch The Bachelor oh yeah it's totally
fine I kind of wish I was like into it I
am like no no - I feel like I just
wouldn't up I always watch the episodes
where they meet their families that's
always the one that's my sister's watch
it and I always watch end up watching
that one with them weirdly mhm and
that's it's always it's interesting and
I can see the appeal I'll say that yes
um my dad watches it I will I will rat
him out on that one
well there's fire now um jeopardy is the
best I'm going real fast down this melon
I was like obsessed with Who Wants to Be
a Millionaire
when I was younger my dad watches very
night and then watch the Padres okay
Wheel of Fortune we hate we know well we
are I like gently don't you nope no but
we usually turn enough I I make sure
that the TV is turned off before Wheel
of Fortune starts
[Music]
there's fires now so you have to watch
out and there's fire yeah by you uh and
of shooting stars I love shooting stars
me too it sounds so beautiful aren't
most shooting stars just asteroids going
through the atmosphere yeah they're
burning up but usually they're only like
the size of like a dying but they make a
huge fireball it's not just it's so cool
that's you don't want to give it a go
then yeah good that's right yes I can't
wait for Mumbai you're healthy I'll beat
you either way the night it's raining I
don't know why it's raining and it's
very very it seems very cold out yeah
it's starting that I think that's the
creator avoiding having to put snow on
the trees while the game
well you'd actually been really well
Thank You Jen you have so much faith in
me
we seem surprised well you seem
surprised by how well I was doing I am
that's cuz I am oops get the magnet Oh
Lucy yeah oh my gosh I just did the best
distance okay I'm feeling real good
about this level knowing you jumped over
the TP oh I got that Matt oh I got a
hovering feather I think did I get a
hammer and feather I think I got it
I was I don't understand what just
happened I got them all done in one turn
job that wasn't those way then Wow
and we got 15 llamas that's great it is
a peaceful game I'm not gonna be good at
that apparently so let's do this Mary
know someone was chasing you I know that
I'm alone I'm so sued by the music that
I miss alternate universes I mean I I
kind of think there is do you believe in
alternate University asking me to
explain it and I couldn't explain it I
believe that there's life outside of
Earth what are you guys talking about
someone else we had liked alternate
universes then I jumped over all those
stars I can't play this game I think you
need some salami some cheese all right
here we go
what are you a snack do you remember the
skiing game where you go down the
mountain and the abdominal snowman
chases you I don't think so
it sounds stressful I've done this game
which is very relaxing do you guys know
what the name of the old abominable
snowman at Disneyland was I do mm-hmm
it's Herald replaced and I don't know
like the one that's known the Guardians
ride is Harold what anyone say anything
creepy about my eating nope nope good
good it's you're getting all fancy with
the snacks is that creepy no I like okay
good we are we're a very sophisticated
bunch that we are okay I'm picking up
speed
oh okay nope nope nope printing it and
it's not no you have to hold it down I
think or with the ramp thing you might
just want to go oh but I collected 25
coins so no check check that one off
your turn no no no keep going keep my
back hurts from carrying the team I
think they're being serious for a moment
any words I was thoroughly concerned
[Music]
um place um working omen or more games
horror games are gonna be coming so
don't worry
Oh are they yeah great I know later on
I'm I'm jealous is there like a murder
mystery game on Google Play because I
would play that I just I just put okay
for that raw I pressed it I pressed it
and it didn't go just do one backflip
that's all you have to do no there's two
more goals that we have to get done baby
steps
okay I'm gonna use my index finger this
time I think maybe that's the T instead
of using my thumb
let's see moment of truth look out for
that no I did it did you see did you see
I press the screen I don't know my
greasy fingers from the lobby and she
it's yeah uh listen it's not working man
that place yeah bet the supervillain did
you see what do we do ih show someone
ask okay I'm trying this one more time
does it work I'm going to be very angry
because I'm pressing the screen I'll
rent you rain introduce everyone for
just Jen shorts Conan yes
and it's I would have got everyone
everyone there's a game called murder
room and they're doin exactly the type
of working you're talking about so we're
gonna download murder room look when we
are done Janet's complete I am going to
play that
why does the rest of the night playing
murder room yep get killed by rock hold
and let go I thought I just had to tap
it
[Music]
I'm usually community yeah and we commit
to things we start things but now I'm
gonna I worry that now it's not work she
thinks anything's wrong
I think because we are tapping we're
tapping I'm pretty tapped out this this
should be okay hold it down the next
time you see oh no oh no no it's just
he's been out you two jump
[Music]
well you what doesn't let you jump them
no see you know I'm searching it I know
I know that's what I said it's all
something's afoot that's it's right I
don't know about this yeah that is
sabotage that is sabotage is everybody
luhan's your badness of the game this is
our first roommate fight so lets it tap
it like a dancer nothing is happening
when I tap it oh you just jumped yeah
maybe you've dip maybe we should tap on
this side it's green so this one is gang
crazy okay that's what we had such
elegant attacks all right okay here we
go here we go I want to get past this
level we're gonna do it I get very
competitive all right do you want me to
check something are you gonna play okay
so now we're using the left side of the
screen
mm-hmm I'm not left-handed so this is
gonna be your 74 concussions and the
husky guy now you asked what the
controls are true yep
look we had it all under control before
like the shooting stars oh it worked on
the left-hand side of the screen we just
been playing so hard that the screen
lost sensitivity oh but no it's working
on the right side too I don't know what
happened everybody but it's better
the developers saw that we were
struggling like we have to fix this
right now oh no I I didn't I I committed
and then I didn't commit I got scared
I'm feeling really good about this run
okay is it a run that you're doing or
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay watch the fire shine no backseat
boarding her backseat boarding heart
right now he jumped a little early
alright let's see here
I believe oh we won't tell anyone who
was playing trivia with a favorite group
of Gemma and Chris Hayes and Chris
Brinson we're playing Sparkle was it fun
I you would have been graded at your oh
we love jeopardy
someone said Jenna's like that teacher
at school that would always have
something negative to say it's true it's
so children no okay okay well no I have
a fire lit under me here I go
I doubt does Jen went does Jen earn the
backseat gaming award no no that she
does not never
okay here we go
so yeah okay 15 llamas that shouldn't be
hard no cutsies tea nuts so easy if you
don't do it in one run I'm gonna be very
disappointed you know I hate the
pressure
yes you're gonna thrive okay here we go
how many miles do you have uh doesn't
matter it doesn't matter I think guys
it's not telling me sorry it's fine
didn't want anything fancy on that jump
just wanted to land it eight I have
eight nine ten wait we're used to oh I
see I really was feeling good about that
one
keep going keep going keep going the
game is called Altos adventure I said on
the screen right there it's really fun
and I'm gonna download it as soon as I'm
home at this and play it for us tonight
because I'm very relaxed and it's great
um someone says Jen seems competitive AF
because I am yeah
who's more competitive between the two
of us that's we're not even included
you're too busy working we watch
jeopardy but let me please
battlefront we're very competitive but
we usually like to team up on
battlefront so then there's no that we
won't fight yeah
oh man I thought that was a rocket as a
llama
it's getting icy cuz I'm gonna ask do we
ever get to meet celebrities if you
really like meta slippery in the show or
just like had a weird encounter I got to
meet Jennifer Lawrence that was oh
that's awesome
I have no I just know I've just done
weird things like painting a green room
at the same time yeah yeah yeah Benedict
Cumberbatch oh when I was an intern the
intern coordinator knew I really liked
Tina Fey it was like oh I need some diet
coke down in the green room and let me
yet carry it down there that's all I
want I just want to like see them I
don't want to speak no I have no desire
to talk to anyone really ever speaking
to these two is already trying out miss
and I got 14 llamas now so that wasn't
15 that's not your right I need the
tough love
that's a tire yeah wait Alto adventure
has an upcoming sequel is that Altos
odyssey snowboarding one do we think
did you guys okay um did you guys ever
know there was a game that my dad bought
for me on like it's like one of those
hands will help game things I think was
like the PlayStation 1 way no I think it
was a PlayStation 1 and it was like it's
called Odyssey or something and it's
like this weird like mutant dude and it
was so much fun I was obsessed with this
I don't know if it was considered a good
game but it's called Odyssey and I loved
it
all right check it out no it's only for
me all right how many okay yes yeah well
I landed it so seven aside morning I'm
not hurting I managers hey there's lamps
like entangled they're floating up in
the air like entangled sing it sing it
for us
are we I don't think we're allowed to oh
we can't it's very expensive song Oh
Wow oh I should have not tried this did
I get anything obviously not we get the
llamas you try again okay Artie it's are
you happening but we have to do we have
to do in one run you have to do it in
one run chest canary 14 llamas is gonna
plot me for the rest of the month
yeah it should is so close I really am
too
are there any new movies or games we're
looking forward to see how that game I
am look as aware where this one I'm
looking forward to some well so I'm
gonna - that's pretty much cards I got
so distracted by the excitement for solo
yes I ran into a rock
haha someone's excited for Avengers I've
only seen one Marvel movie which one
spider-man homecoming Oh Kingdom Hearts
3 I just started playing Kingdom Hearts
on my ps4 I like it cuz I like Donald
Duck
I wish Donald Duck was in a more okay
oh I jumped over the Lana Altos and am i
doing Odyssey is already on iOS oh
really
I don't know I know I want to see black
pants or - someone said to see black I
have like this really good a Donald Duck
thing okay uh you won't have to wait
much longer to stream Cathy's McDonald's
commercial cuz she's coming up so soon a
minute
[Music]
okay I'm gonna miss this music I wonder
if they have it on iTunes
maybe who I hopped on that rock music is
definitely a thing I just hopped on that
rock did you see
someone wants a Kathy chant I won't give
her that tension now I won't give her
that pleasure you have to keep her
humble yeah okay you got this Jen get
those 15 okay
14 that numbers been a hot for the rest
of my life Oh guys just what Big Time
end of our time
all right guys this is it I didn't get
the 15 llamas and I'm sorry
virtual chat um does this game is really
fun by really fast um I hope I never see
either of you know I'm going to bed okay
okay so it's the top of the hour right
now what time is it it's 10:00
let's check in with Conan it's 10
o'clock at night and we are 10 hours
into this incredible experiment a little
fun fact did you know that I'm on the
board of the JFK Presidential Library
that's a true story
I'm very proud to be part of that
library cuz John F Kennedy was born
where Brookline Massachusetts in 1917
where is Conan from Brookline
Massachusetts both of us rose to great
heights and changed the world with our
charisma that was a mistake I apologize
for that last part anyway look at the
Kennedy Library gave me they gave me
this cool amazing bust of John F Kennedy
right there and I keep this in my office
along with other presidential
memorabilia but this is in my office I
just want to make you aware a little fun
fact
Conan's on the board of the JFK
Presidential Library
you can probably win a Trivial Pursuit
game with that or I get a free drink at
a bar
try it again I mentioned a drink I'm
mentioning drinks a lot I should steak
anyway we're gone now up next is our
co-workers Diane again
[Music]
what a pleasure so much okay here we go
I just thought the games were magically
gonna start you need a tablet to start
okay I feel like we should say we
shouldn't right um hello Internet I'm
Diane Hartman oh um Diane and I work at
Conan I'm Kathy and I also work in Conan
yeah um Diane what do you do at copán
I'm the post production coordinator so I
kind of just I don't do anything
actually technical or crazy talented but
I am there for the people who are doing
that the editors the writers our graphic
designers anyone who needs something I
should
ideally no we're what goes where and
when I think so what do you do I'm the
writers assistant so I just assist the
writers and it's great should we sign in
or do we oh right Oh fun
yeah so we're playing one of our
favorites Laura Croft yeah we think we
think she killed Hills things she in the
tombs she kills stuff do we want to look
someone recognize you think someone
recognized you from twitch they say it's
the girl from the Macdonald ah I'm so
glad you brought this up
ladies and gentlemen Kathy oh it
recently started McDonald's commercial
that aired during the Oscars opposite
Chrissy Teigen it was very fun I also
like on YouTube someone's asking where
is Alison I'm not sure which Alison
they're referring to um but I don't know
yeah okay well you should look elsewhere
okay so what are we doing I don't know
I'm guessing I entrance seems promising
yes I feel like we should begin there oh
I love this game all right
great great here we go happy to be along
for the journey
yes I'm am i hogging do you want to know
okay
no we both are very competitive and
neither of us are super gamers so that
could be a potentially terrible yeah I
might get angry yeah so I'm sorry and it
may apologies for that
but this is fun this is fun just
learning where I should
oh I'm sorry I think you can tap her
where to go okay
oh I see you have to swipe great oh no
we're good we're good someone asked if
you play any video games Thank You
windsock from twitch um
do do you play video games often are you
a gamer gal um not so much anymore I
find I get very addicted to things as
you can see I'm very distracted right I
love it cuz I'm so addicted already uh
so I find that if I want to be at least
a little bit productive I can't play but
I used to sure we've talked about this
we have a mutual adoration for Harvest
Moon love any Harvest Moon fans out
there yeah a Harvest Moon
Oh God for those of you who don't know I
can't imagine there's a large group of
people who don't know what Harvest Moon
is but it's like a farming game it's the
most chill like into it the most chill
the whole objective of the game is to
build a life and to live a life on a
farm which i think is a nice escape
first move yeah I'm that sounds great
yeah I would love that yeah Harvest Moon
is not about growing pot to my knowledge
I believe you grew like carrot yeah
and each I mean it's actually pretty
accurate as
it's like seasons for certain vegetables
you know you like grow tomatoes in the
summer and you grow sweet potatoes in
the fall cause they like the cooler
weather I know a lot about gardening the
harvest man do you garden in real life
not here I mean we live in Los Angeles
so I haven't quite mastered how to have
a garden here but my mom my mom back
home loves she has a huge garden so I'm
very like I aspire to be one day I'm do
you want to do you want to take a try
yeah catch me up what you have done
don't you like you're trying to if you
swipe that's how you okay and then it's
not going to fall when I tap no it only
falls if you double tap the little lever
and you want to double tap it what I see
it there in the no move it ah you I've
already mentioned today okay all right
yeah I'm walking we're doing it yeah
making good time
are we being timed um someone is asking
what game this is so uh this is our very
favorite game other than Harvest Moon of
course
Laura Croft we have so far not killed
anyone so I guess my oh I don't do it
fries I will you fall into it yeah I
guess we're gonna find out oh oh so I
have to choose which way you know cuz
it'll probably crack once I owe you and
left hey easy more that way but maybe
there's a switch over here what do you
guys think yeah she left her right
everyone's in bed everyone's asleep it's
fine I'm just gonna go left
great this seems like a good choice no
I'm gonna climb this wall I'm a climber
oh my gosh that's so nice someone on
YouTube
Marielle Terran is
giving some love to touka we love to go
do you love touka to those of you just
joining in touka is Beth and Alisa and
just cat oh no what happened just fine I
just hey it's fine I hit a crack on the
wall in it oh okay made me fall
oh no no consequences which way shall I
go you can go up you guys
tap tap oh I'm learning and that's a
movie movie we go oh no no no no give it
another tap oh great okay and now we're
done
I like oh I see now can I just jump why
isn't she jumping you're Laura Croft she
can um I accidentally made her do a
somersault I don't know how to make her
do that again I don't know what that is
but I found it
2:06 quartz is fun ah it was that
sparkly oh yeah oh I don't think I can
do that that's fine
everything's fine every we're doing
great we're doing great
here we go sweet whoa whoa we did it
on to level four oh I guess we're just
masters at this I guess we are
oh do you like to please do oh my gosh
thank you so much I wouldn't want to
take the reins of things I apparently
can't read fast enough to keep up a lot
of nice things people are saying just
it's hard to decipher through them all
[Music]
oh great nothing great just do that
we'll kick username 360 Cathy's a
natural-born winner first she won my
heart
now she's winning this game but I did it
doesn't matter the timing on that
comment was great because I really just
I'll give some love to us Aussies we
love Australia I've never been have you
been to Austria I would like to it's a
long play is what I need right yeah yeah
I actually I have a lot of friends from
Australia oh yeah yeah Marcus are those
room in Keighley yeah it's at least four
that's a lot of Australian friends oh my
gosh doing this you know I I
accidentally tap tap Tala to you
oh we're okay we're okay I think you did
well don't hit that guy the little
yellow lever ah can you just like walk
on the sidewalk
oh oh I see I made a bit just yeah there
we go
oh I think I make the jump just ask her
to make the jump how can I can I don't
know and that was a pretty cool well
tumble you didn't know I did it again
yeah today did I lose again you uh are
you excited about the new tomb raider
movie um I don't know a lot about it but
I love movie so I will check it out
Alicia Alicia vikander yeah is Laura
crocked who is great yeah i'm i am
excited about her I feel like she's
great I think I really really ruined
this for us okay can you just like get
swallowed by one of those holes and let
us start over and she just won't even
like that's a bad idea I'm not gonna
drop in a hole she's really doing a good
job not letting me just jump off yeah I
will say when I did play video games I
think the most recent video game console
I played was a ps2 where did you find
that I just found that in the corner but
it's not helping my case oh you're still
laughing I mean do you want to give I
really oh I got us into a corner um yeah
there's no other way to go can you just
like try a swiping some of the hidden
the levers again oh yeah let's see let's
go just give him a get more push let's
see I can only access this lever now
it's fine now look at that now you can
climb the wall and get up to the top
mm-hmm yeah okay this whole time I don't
know can you
okay can you here let me do it yeah
please take me just a couple havethey
swipes I just wanted to make that leap
over there she's not not doing no okay I
really got us into a pickle
how are people liking this I feel like
someone's telling us bare bare ski 180
you saying swing back to the top one how
do you swing hold swing okay swing we're
trying to swing trying really hard
oh man she's reaching like she wants to
do it I mean I I really love that she's
not givin up on us even though we've
given up try I feel like the more I just
tap it'll work
yeah yeah I mean it's not the case hmm
man well I guess it's it's possible to
lose this game you see oh yeah someone's
telling us we got to restart
oh sure oh oh this seems you take a
picture okay thank you to everyone who's
saying restart yeah just restart
honestly you would think that's the
it's given yeah we needed that thank you
see here's the thing in Harvest Moon you
cannot restart so that's why I was this
person is affirming as like just take
note of this
well the freaks thank you for the
encouragement doses we need it oh yeah
oh yeah okay alright so let's do this so
we know that the top lever oh I already
forgot okay I think I remember actually
because they're colored they're
color-coded the same way oh you're right
oh this is smart and then I will just
drop on phone wait where am I trying to
go where's the ideal oh I want to get oh
I see I see I see I have already ruined
it I believe I don't know no you're good
cuz you still have that if you go this
way that 100 yeah if you go this way and
then the gold one will move up and then
that takes you to the lovely that's be
right but I think eventually I need to
hit that one again you think yeah
because I want to I want to climb up
that guy oh you know I'm saying hmm well
wait I'm gonna I'm gonna get this yeah
we're we're here to finish this game and
we will do it I'm gonna restart one more
time okay we're gonna get there and it's
gonna be great
I found a quartz I think oh I was trying
to restart and man oh man just got that
natural quartz talent okay here we go
duck duck here we go here we go I think
this is only ranked like a too far
behind all right we'll get that yeah no
this is great okay we're gonna we're
gonna do some conscious choices here
let's see alright
top-down right and now I'm going to go
to the first level first I think
actually I think it's green and then
gold because I think you're trying to
get up to this you know but don't I
think I want to I think I want to die
eventually
oh because I think I need to hit I think
I need to hit the gold first and then
I'll hit the gold again no harder okay
so we do gold yeah we're just gonna
start over one more time regretting
their decision it's warm in here right
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
Kathy if I don't get it this time kill
me I mean every time someone's doing a
sad face and like we'll get there do the
upper one first you know what I'm gonna
take that advice for the fame
all right yeah I didn't want you to do
that I just wanted you to do a little
climb down you were doing your best and
that's all that matters
all right we're gonna go up we're gonna
do that upper level first just like our
fans said yes so we're doing green like
you guys said thank you so much just
don't want it here do you need yeah I
think okay because we we do want
okay we're fine we're okay
yeah hit this one goes uh and then oh
just climbing just go across ah okay
thank you so much I feel bad about thank
you
we are not welcome here he's like you
took too long oh boy oh that's right it
seems nice
yeah ice cream oh okay
that's not where ice creams go keep
snakes you say someone said your new
Conan was the last clue listen that's
good oh wait is this something nope it's
always good make sure I know the last
one wasn't anything but I'm just gonna
check nope this one is also not right I
mean as long as we confirm oh I'm then
we go that way okay that sounds like a
great yes have you met any of the
celebrity guests on the show I don't
know I haven't have you don't think I
have actually trying to think if it was
it was very much and I think
as my family asked me this all the time
- they're like oh do you did you talk to
Nicole when years olin or you know
things like that and I'm like actually I
work throughout the day and I don't
really have to do that you know it's and
it's kind of like I mean here it's a
it's fun but it is still a professional
environment
all right jobs come first
[Music]
do they not I mean it's yeah it's just
kind of like we do our jobs yeah yeah
you work you are doing phenomenally
thank you so much I'm so sorry that
honestly that's on me that's my bad I
knew that was I but I did it anyway I
think I am the how do you say it in
context of this movie it's all right
where's our guarantee we're guys this is
all about I think the lesson to learn
here is it's about doing your badges
it's a metaphor almost for life you know
they're like you get bit by the snake
you just get back on that horse
it was great well you have to go behind
the thing that's like I got other times
oh gosh that's do you want to oh no oh
no did I really kill us oh no I think we
have infinite life okay great and if not
I apologize I lost a lot to walk climb
all right okay yeah yeah
wait you want to go to the left first
because these guys don't kill you I see
oh I got excited I don't want to be no
thank you I appreciate it any and all
advice and I just tapped the snake dude
shoot yeah or no you swipe out - you're
like okay yeah we're good and I can do
to their sides as well yeah you just
can't great sorry right
someone just said what am i watching -
first time gamers that's like basically
correct for me I haven't gamed in a
while have you
you haven't gamed in a while huh you
know this is a secret not a lot of
people know but I still have my Game Boy
Advance and I do sometimes play that but
that is not this it's like I have
buttons and I have I have buttons yeah
is is all I have to say is the Game Boy
Advance is that different from the Game
Boy Color
yeah yes it's a it's a newer model the
gameboy color was like pretty
groundbreaking because it was the first
color version of that handheld consoles
yes and I did have one of those too but
then Game Boy advances were like pretty
cool sometimes giving us a good hint
Balor is saying to go - hit the lever oh
why is a very much Wow thank you so much
done amazing where would we be without
you so we don't even have any snakes but
I'm okay
oh I see I see I see I see I see I see
oh I grow up so fast you guys are gonna
rue the day you're getting way too
confident I will die oh this is great
this is great you're doing great thank
you I'm still gonna kill this guy
I didn't have to just falls off the wall
Wow I filled it you know what they're
playing a game will read it later yeah
we don't have all day
oh we haven't seen this jump action oh
yeah he's similar to walking oh wow
it seems like it would waive that yeah
oh I guess I don't have to be able to
reach it I can't just all right this is
fine will it see me from this far away
no don't think so oh my goodness
somersault a just go on and we're just
gonna go on yeah why not yeah and
whatever you get extra points for
killing all I really hope so
oh I see no no sorry too far yeah
oh I can't
what about that lever will that do it oh
I ca
oh no come on Laura you know what I was
trying to do okay here we go oh it's so
much flare for no reason
oh cool then you go right yeah and I
think I think that about
dragon the maze of snakes
I like that lizard guy oh this is fun Oh
what this is this is your Debra our
territory can we jump rotating spike oh
it was okay
oh boy honestly Kathy oh okay okay okay
it's gonna come back the next one okay
so oh oh we're good we're good
Oh everything guys don't worry okay ooh
what do I do now
oh I see aah go away we don't want you
razor someone just said now you two are
making it look too easy
oh stop it we're just fast learners
yeah we are very smart I still got
plenty of fails left in me oh oh you
just stay tuned we've got a full hour I
have no concept of time
oh my god I knew it
hi I enjoyed that bye
oh my god I am sure I mean that was that
was pretty crazy you just did that I'm
so oh thank you so much thank God thank
you okay live for your support
well you've got oh you got oh my god
okay here we go
I'm still seeing where's Alison on the
YouTube chat I think
is you so I don't know but it's like
refreshing or if it's just tight Twin
Snakes you just hide twinsen I said did
you would you do I look down for a
second I found a fragment of it I'm not
sure what that means yet but I'm sure
that'll become more clear oh boy this
time goes on do you think I just need to
call myself I'm pretty sure I've been
calling it Laura Croft if I've been
saying that Lara oh I'm so sorry
everyone
that's my bad again
um fell off the wall Aladdin is a rubber
ring I guess so
where are the livers did anyone see it
oh yeah it's below that okay here we go
follow my everything's fine Wow
excellent oh wait that's good
can we swing across that maybe can we do
it quick jump oh she's gonna just jump
down she wouldn't she wouldn't do that
for us earlier I'm gonna rate this at
the end so I'm just I'll do with you Oh
someone's asking what are our names so
to remind everyone oh so what
marshmallow crew thank you so much for
letting everyone know that we're Cathy
and Diane oh thank you so much we're
clearly concentrating very hard on this
game oh they make it look easy
yeah everything's fine
Jamie no that's great I often forget
that I can just tap on those I don't
have to go to Rio right that's a gaming
instinct of mind that is incorrect um
but we got a whole head that's fun hey
that's great
Oh that guy's stuck sucks does suck
all right oh I see I understand okay
[Music]
okay there's one lever
it's Kathy with a cat is Kathy with a
kid thanks for asking marshmallow crew
you both seem like very nice people
that's very nice Diane's very nice I can
speak to that
thank you Dianne has a desk right next
to mine Diana fun fact has two desks a
cone and you do but one of those is
right next to mine so that's just like
fun fact is a fun for everyone
oh I haven't been up there very much
lately because we've been pretty busy
right right with all the activities that
cranes up to right but occasionally I
see Diane right next to me she sneaks up
I don't even hear you but sometimes I'll
look over and I'll be like I'm Diane's
here I'm not one to announce my arrival
on the third floor I'll just be like
that's me sitting at my desk oh that's
great very much yeah
mm-hmm no more snakes you know my
nemec's this see oh this is a fun
question what's the funniest thing that
has happened to you at work
it's hard for me to choose one yeah it's
just so many funny things there's a lot
of funny things we work with very funny
people and I feel like most of my
interactions with them are fun yeah
trying to think because it's hard to
it's hard to describe without them like
knowing the people you have to be I mean
I feel like anytime Conan is on the
third floor when I'm on the third floor
is always always something happens
that's because he and the writers they
love to give each other a hard time so
I'm often like caught in the middle of
that oh there was one time maybe like
two weeks ago that let's see if I could
talk and play at the same time I fun
challenge wrongly confident in myself
but there is a time maybe like oh I bet
I can throw this for a distance you
think oh yeah oh boy I was just this is
a teaching moment for us all sometimes
you can throw a spear and sometimes you
can and I think the snake was flashing
because it was like just tap on the
snake right you didn't have to swipe he
didn't have to swipe but I mean but
anyway so I was saying like maybe a week
and a half or two weeks ago I was okay
here we go now I don't have that anymore
oh oh no then what are you gonna do
after this story yeah started a million
times and the payoff will be worth I
can't um
what am I supposed to do this guy oh you
can shoot him from the side another
spear but I don't think I can okay I was
gonna say there was a moment on the
third floor a couple we're gonna have a
go edge and I was standing up there and
one of the riders that I often play
basketball with he came up to me and was
like you know talking about the team he
had just gotten new shoes and and then
Conan came up like in the middle of that
conversation he walked up and so the
writer his name's Dan he like turned to
Conan was like telling him the same
thing about the basketball team and like
look at my new shoes I just got new
shoes and yeah we play once a week and
all this stuff about the basketball team
and then Dan left and um and the girl
who was next to me
her name's Liz Liz was like telling
Conan she said actually Diane plays on
that team with Dan and she's on that
basketball team and Conan was like and
he didn't mention her a single time and
so the next time Dan came over maybe a
minute later and Conan was like we're
gonna ask Diane questions about herself
and her experience on the basketball
team and like all the writers gathered
around and just sat and like started
throwing questions at me it was much too
much and I was very overwhelmed but it
was it was so funny I mean they're all a
bunch of dummies in the best way but
yeah Conan was like you didn't mention
it's a good time hold on
yeah that's great um where am I Oh Lara
Lara go to the left oh my god more
snakes they don't even know what's
coming
I'm just gonna hop on this ecliptic move
here okay Wow I feel alive I mean here's
some things to think about when we rate
this game yeah it gives you confidence
it should yeah great bye bye oh just all
on a roll I'm gonna go ahead and take a
gander and say this is okay um it looks
like YouTube still is on oh wait no
nevermind I so see where's Allison and
again um not sure who Allison is I'm so
sorry I wish I knew
well we'll find out for you by the end
of this game we'll do our best
you know what do this later
oh yes
man I love killing snakes my dating
profile man I love killing snakes all
right who's next man sup dog Mike you
sit here
sorry oh no I'm just pointing out that
sup don't mind me just said those poor
snakes just trying to get some Sun sad
face and we're just killing them while
they're trying to tan yeah sorry
really puts perspective into this whole
game I feel like it's a trap to kill
that one do you have a spirit I'm gonna
do it I'm just a killing machine
shouldn't brag about that I feel I'm so
sorry for screaming I don't know why
it's your eternity let's see let's see
let's see let's see what okay okay so we
know okay let's
well now I'm in a pickle
I shouldn't have my spear yeah I know
that's what I'm saying it was a trout we
should just start over okay well I'm
just gonna die that's really brave thank
you so much we did go down in a non room
somebody I just I just uh I just knew it
was time to go okay okay we're not gonna
make the same mistake a third time ya
know so we're not gonna kill you even
though you want us to what if we killed
this guy first yeah great idea okay but
now we're in the same pickle cuz if I
killed that I feel like you should be
here we go wait let me try this I feel
like you should be able to kill two
snakes with one spear Oh do you think if
maybe Wow I already tried to do it and
it wouldn't let me
it was pretty firm about that I think
for sure you should say it like you did
and kill that first egg me the right and
then let's try
[Music]
yes cuz then yes that's the one because
they go and kill the reverse guy yeah
sorry look we understand honestly again
just trying our best
realistically you should be able to
retrieve the spirit thank you I was just
thinking that myself
why does this fear disappear it
disappears into the snake huh with the
snake where does the snake carcass go I
have a lot of questions that looks like
they're gonna be sauce yeah but this
guy's stuck so let me see what this does
right I don't move them to that middle
okay but I'm still safe here mm-hmm I
think you should keep him stuck on the
on the not go apart yeah you're right
because that's I guess that was not what
I meant
wait wait oh just walked into it jump
right on oh man do you wanna give this
one a try sure I would love to thank you
okay all right here we go
Oh someone is asking uh Sam Sam's
anarwick
oh gosh he just disappeared he asked if
we could read the comments right now and
yes we can
oh yeah of course um except on YouTube
which seems to be I still asking where
Allison is yeah someone said is have you
met Jordan Ashlyn ski and as he has
awkward as real life in the videos uh I
don't interact with Jordan too much do
you interact with Jordan a lot
on your day to day um I it depends I
some days I do some days I don't but
enough I mean I feel like we have a good
friendship that I I usually I tell my
family I'm like he's genuinely like
passionate about espresso and Italian
culture and you know personal grooming
those kinds of things are very genuine
and sincere yeah but I think when he
does get with Conan Conan likes to poke
that button I might bring it out more
but it really I mean I've had
conversation with George Lansky about
wine and about coffee because he has
opinions and usually they're pretty good
okay what do you do with you my friends
well cuz we want to get that spear oh
how can we get that razor to the other
side you see how there's like a little
diet
I just don't hope
and then maybe move one so get stuck and
then go don't move right back
you know I'm saying boy I think for sure
ah oh I have an idea okay yeah yeah this
is what I want to here we go oh that's
not what I wanted to do I'm so sorry
everyone is just going to take a few
more dr-dos we're so close I can feel it
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah okay okay good
okay cool I'm really excited to be your
trap mare plan
Oh bye-bye little razor
I gotta go kill snake you done been
killed all right let's get out of here
okay oh you get another spear yeah oh
and there's like a little spa my my dad
said badge um here we go clear simply
retired superstar something is rumbling
and I don't like that
the snake is haha once again we were
eight you one more gun that's my
patience alright there's a remember you
said you liked it like someone map an
exhibit at later to meet the king I
think he's definitely gonna kill you
gets his hands on you oh well there's a
little lizard tongue you know I talk a
big game but that would hurt maybe it
was nice knowing you know they were
luckier when they're lying
[Music]
do you mind yeah I was like this is
gonna happen just like you don't mess
with my friends no Diane will get you if
you mess with her friends well let me
tell you I'll lead you into it deep dark
hole okay oh this guy this guy let's
find out what to do with this okay I
have an idea
he doesn't see me yes someone is Lady
Gold - marshmallow crew is saying
reptile murder and we are very sad about
the reptiles being murdered what
happened I wanted to go oh I see oh if I
go that way he's gonna see you but if
you oh if I'm gonna go this way
yep
huh max follow me man it's safe here I
[Laughter]
really buy into that time I was so
confident really really believed in you
I laughed at him is he really do you
have to turn or and now you know at
least the first part and then the second
part honestly at this point
oh my you say okay well you kill easy
this one's deceptive okay so wait and
this guy will chase you I just want you
to like beep I know okay so wait my I've
got you my strategy I see my strategy ok
clucking okay sorry
you'll just go right yeah somewhat Darth
iron I just said can you get Alison look
I honestly I wish we could I wish we
could mean honestly at this point I'm
starting to get worried about I don't
know who she internet is very worried
about Alison and now I am too Oh someone
just said have you ever been to a
writer's meeting what's it like um you
know every day I do
it's very fun they're usually okay let's
Harlan questions until we meet in our
lab we are in the backs of our lines I'm
legitimately Stern I love this phrase so
easy peasy
yeah just didn't even suspect it my
heart is racing talk about not learning
from your mistakes here we go easy peasy
over the cracks and up we can feel the
blood draining from my yeah okay this is
all fine and good we're having a great
time yes there's that day I'm like
already sweating just anticipating the I
know I know okay okay
does it we know that's what he's gonna
see me there he's saying this think
twice GK saying the spear is a trap all
caps so he is serious I think I have an
idea the vertical hole is unhelpful is
what they're saying near the ledge okay
[Laughter]
he's a big dumb believe in you and that
was a mistake on my part because you had
it in you the whole time I would rush I
mean okay ten out of ten by I'm a pro no
gosh the power is going to my head and I
can feel that oh my gosh
I've been doing in my hands okay
back to the right yes yeah it's a lot of
fun we meet I guess it we don't really
we sometimes me in the morning sometimes
in the afternoons
the writers pitch around jokes and
pitches and I'll write them down in a
doc mhm
and then I'll email it to them if
necessary is it a lot are you like
typing super fast and like trying to
keep up I am constantly well for the
most part I'm usually typing but in my
elementary school we had a typing class
I don't want to brag but I I feel like
I'm a pretty good typer that was barely
a brag oh yeah I feel good about it
great so you keep up you're fine I think
so but you would recommend someone who's
on that kind of job to definitely be
very proficient or at least like
understand your own note-taking skills
right oh okay here is another lizard
well I guess I'm just gonna try this out
and first time is usually not great oh
gosh okay yeah I know you're good you're
good you're fine you're fine okay well
that is um only I don't think you're
funny I'm not fine I'm not fine I you're
gonna get eaten by oh my gosh but you
know it we'll get it back okay okay okay
I mean I guess I just yeah it's okay to
try
I was beginning to read the feed but I
was honest I couldn't it's a lot to
focus on yeah um do you do you want to
try this
oh yeah sure and you want to do feed
control what did ya what happened when
you hit that lever doesn't no one popped
up you okay okay great um youtube still
frozen on Alison I have an idea
oh oh that wasn't it that's not what I
wanted to do but my finger slipped
when diana has an idea guy you just stay
tuned yeah here we go
hello I say now come follow me I would
like to go down yeah thank you
alright then we're just gonna lead them
on this way oh alright you can always go
around in a circle right yeah yeah I
just wanted to be put on that block you
know yeah I got you I got you I like I
don't get that chase you chase you you
know I think I do need that actually cuz
I I don't I think if I go down and hit
that lever he's gonna right snatch me
yeah I hate but I oh he's probably fine
he's just in that little ditch yeah
honestly the most lenient of our doings
I would say I didn't giggle equally when
it happened here we go
all right oh great
all right oh no I have an idea I will
not be tricked by this fear oh that's
not what I thought would happen we're
gonna go back that direction I thought I
was gonna go the other way
Wow once again I'm just good we're doing
fine just gonna kill it and that's for
sure a mistake it's for sure a mistake
but it's okay that guy's gone I know I'm
gonna die by this guy for sure but how
could you fix that Oh was it maybe like
going down and doing the other letter
yeah I think it was like I could have I
could have it could have done I could
have done better
mm-hmm it's what I think let me see how
long I can't I mean I need that guy to
chase me but what is this - let's just
see what it does just let's just see oh
they both do the same thing both seem to
be a little unhelpful
I hope this does the same exact thing
all right so Andy goes gonna get this
guy to chase me now Cathy hold on - hold
on - pants oh and he dances he's like so
excited that he ain't you
he wouldn't even chase me and I feel a
fool all right this is what I do you
mind fight no no I have this idea
okay let's see it no I want to do that
yes and I want him to see me he sees you
this is you may have been mistake people
are laughing that was good I think you
had it Diane whoa which means at one
point you had it
thanks illumination and honestly this
okay you want it you want to try it I'll
see it okay okay all right
you didn't need first and we believe
that was correct right well this person
just apology no in midday weren't
talking to us I was like you can go to
bed anytime okay let's take it should I
do this no you need to follow you
so I think oh no no no you're fine
you're more than fine you know I know I
know
yeah you're good okay sorry you're gonna
wait well
I think you I think you do want him to
follow you across that way because you
want him to go up on top of that flock
so he has to like see you do it first
okay I'm a lizard psychologist now oh
man I'm sorry sorry sorry this is my no
we're gonna get this okay hey I'm
running out of time right right okay
Jamie bye bye and hopefully oh gosh he's
so close he truly is but I think you're
fine Oh oh my gosh thank you everyone
Oh careful do you know if you go up
there he'll eat you can I do this um oh
oh I think oh wait what if I do this
what if I do this guys guys guys does
that make a difference you know see cuz
I think you need to be standing on top
of that great block and then spear him
from there you gotta I gotta kill the
first guy then right yeah but then he's
gonna kill me yeah you have to kill the
upstairs lizard from above speaking my
language exactly
this is a mobile game it's a Google Play
game it's just what is MLG stood mega
mega level gamer that's not real
thank you for real I just put words
together that I assumed oh alright here
we go here we go here we go
naive you never oh my gosh oh my gosh I
can't get to the sparkly thing major
league major league gaming
god what happened
that wasn't me that wasn't me that
wasn't me I I was it was learning what
MLD stood for and then suddenly did you
beat it did I I don't you yes my snake
part I think that big old snake can you
kill them the first time you let's have
it look closely at the path to be animus
crimes that we all miss cathy's big
moment by defining MLG yeah oh maybe you
can just kill me aside I think now we're
nearing our time right we are so I guess
the big takeaways try your best
I guess should we read the full nouns
honestly even if you fall through the
cracks and a lizard eats your head
mm-hmm just do your best your best um
get up and snake very good yeah snakes
like what snakes like this suntan is
something we learned that's true a lot
of clear is Alison where is Alison who
is Ali in the next hour hopefully
they'll find Alison I can only hope or
one of these snakes Alison is a lizard
Alison but 10 out of 10 once we got the
hang of you know the whole swiping yeah
yeah why me things right
man remember when we couldn't figure out
how to climb that wall and switch those
levers Oh we grew so much we grew so
much huh in this hour um now I think we
might as well uh Oh take a little break
yes the top of the hour is there
something that's just coming to the top
of our head yeah what we're gonna say
night uh let's check in with Conan yeah
great
well it's 11 o'clock and if you're
watching this it means you're not
watching my show why aren't you watching
the show on TBS I don't matter I'm not
watching it either I haven't watched it
in years is Andy Richter still on it
it's Randy Randy bender Randy you licked
her anyway happy 11 o'clock
all right next let's check out this
video of Conan and blaze a year and game
stream Conan O'Brien there we go look at
this all right look we're playing we're
playing the best game to make it's rude
not to make eye contact I'm sorry
because it's rude you're gonna don't
care here in the middle of the battle
when someone and when another adult
enters the room okay and you're gaming
you make icon okay resume your game okay
thank you when we're playing airplane
battle Bay we're going through ah some
of the best games of 2017 on the Google
Play Store you've never played a mobile
game have you would again like on your
mobile device like and of course I have
I played a mobile game upwards yeah oh
sure okay
of course I have yes all right well some
stupid I love mobile games yeah they
keep me from you know accepting the life
and the reality around me that's the
best thing about a mobile game there we
go all right you want to play battle Bay
yes okay all right so your love battle
Bey battle plates awesome so here's how
you play so uh all right so basically
who wouldn't want to play battle I don't
know it's amazing all right let's say hi
to the chat there's a paycheque pillow
pants shush oh be a loose amish ah
huzzah
and he mutts a wild Conan Crone and
roast me say hi Patrick hi Patrick
let contemplate dumbass okay okay
alright I just yeah yeah you so much the
sources let Co not a all right you want
to play oh there's this game I love call
flippin legend I think I have a
long-lost son out there yeah yeah call
me we got to catch up man all right you
want to play uh there's a game
alright let's place the battle base yeah
so basically this game uh you're a ship
you know Ashley let's get out of here
let's play a different game this is one
of my favorite games okay this game is
called flippin legend yes alright
flippin legend so what I love about
flippin legend is it's very simple which
will be great for this dude and you're
an archer okay right and I and you're a
very acrobatic art yes okay and so yeah
here we go
alright so all you need to do is you
just tap either the left or the right
side and you're gonna jump back and
forth and you want to avoid the bad guys
so you'll see but jump back and forth
and oh I mean you want to kill the bad
guys so yes to keep jumping how do I
shoot an arrow if I'm an archer you
don't so go you want to hit that guy you
okay you don't want to hit the pit all
right wait wait about what where why
when do I shoot well you can hit it you
can hit this thing to shoot an arrow but
you'll jump back it's kind of a okay
what happened tied you tied well I don't
understand person so hey listen yes I
know you're all gonna be snarky about my
skills with a Z but it wasn't clear to
me you just handed me this thing I
couldn't me how I play okay so basically
there's a time limit and it's counting
down and so you need to kill guys to
keep getting but how do you kill them
you you jump on them you just jump on
the but you set up an archer yeah but
that's not how an archer would function
in the world he doesn't jump he shoots
an arrow but he's like an AK is like an
acrobatic art trees like a ninja is
never shooters era well so you have once
in a while you can shoot an arrow
what are you you can only jump diagonal
you know chess yeah okay it's not but
what does that have to do with art you
I'm just saying like in chess you know
they're dead don't call this an archer
game
that's stupid what are you okay it's
like Jesus in archery so not an archer
game no all right so call it Archer but
call it hop-on crushed pop on crush
let's try to get hop on
all right so you can only go diagonally
so you want to tap left and right right
right so to keep going and your time is
running out there at the top see so you
want to jump on those guys but sometimes
so sometimes it's not gonna line up oh
there you go see you hit your arrow
thing you don't want to jump into the
pit you got to go fast you gotta go fast
like pow pow pow there you go
pow pow yep there you see this dump what
you doing out your hand
okay I'm just charging there you go oh
yeah look at this yes wait see oh yeah
I'm supposed to go this speed yeah well
you can go this is the way you play
chess chess is a great analogy
I just put no thought into it you just
mash around I mean just in terms of like
this game this game this game would not
have passed muster in 1979 I'm just
saying that it's a you know like that
you can only move certain ways there you
go see you're killing all the dudes yeah
you're doing really good man you're like
doing well you don't say good are you
doing let's use proper grammar you're
doing us awesome is that can you say
awesome yeah you say awesome all the
time
you're not a real adult have you had a
net do you have you had an adult
relationship in your life no I mean not
with a person or like a video game
whatever
all right no not with a person with a
video game like I you know there's you
walk around the office wearing ironic
watches and saying awesomesauce that's
true I got a watch on today it has a dot
in the law that's great his watch in
doesn't even tell time it's just that
because he's such a hipster yeah then
who needs to know what time it is right
that's true yeah well you know I'm just
saying you know time is a construct
anyway right it's not all just time
isn't real same room with you you don't
have to yet okay I'm just all right all
right you want to play oh and watching I
apologize me play he yells way too much
he thinks everything's awesome
everything is awesome is great yeah
yesterday some mustard spilled on the
floor he pointed out and said isn't that
awesome all right wait speaking of
mustard speaking of mustard how about a
cooking game yes a game where you cook
things this game is called cooking craze
it's one of the best to pick up and play
yeah if you don't like cooking yeah I
don't like cooking what better way to
spend your free time than playing a game
where you simulate the thing you don't
like to do have you ever what you do
what's your I make one thing all right
what do you make I make a tuna fish
sandwich with chopped onion
mayonnaise and I put it on toast gross I
also can make new ramen noodles so I can
make those two things and I like to have
them together oh I like those two things
ramen noodles a bowl of ramen noodles
and a tuna fish sandwich with some onion
in it those are the only things that I
made all the time that I was a writer
sir Night Live Simpsons
all the shows I've worked on when all
those years that I was alone working on
my craft yeah I'd call it a craft that's
how I worked on that
that's what fueled you that was your
creative fuel in those years those teen
years if you're calling in if you wonder
why I'm dressed like a 1930s newsman I
don't know we have a lot of work today
and I was really busy so I came right
from a workout because you don't just
get this body and I wore my kooky hat
and who's what why the ladies are
laughing my body remark Pansear is
asking to pregnant you present pregnant
them on and pregnant me I don't know if
that pregnant sout a verb is Conan a
real comedian no really
not really I love it though the you're
asking me I said you seem genuinely
confused no I'm not a real comedian
those are you know what Sinbad wimple
can make hot pockets whether you had a
hot pocket what's your position on hot
pockets movie my position there that's
an efficient way to to eat something bad
quickly what do you want do you want to
uh do you want to do a quick cooking
game quickly before you go I know you
have a show to do
they're very very quick yeah let's do
the cooking game all right we're gonna
do all right we're gonna do this is
gonna make donuts are you donut fan and
I love Donuts I try not to eat them sure
because it's all sugar and carbs yes
nothing in there and every time you eat
a donut you shorten your life this is a
true fact by one year that's been proven
if you have like eight doughnuts you're
gonna be dead in at least a year if
you're in your 40s all right so let's
make some donuts here we go so here we
go we're trying to please that's a
stereotypical view of a chef I don't
think it's he's clearly Italian II am
making a pizza pie so what am i doing
all right so there's gonna be customers
that are gonna come
and they're gonna have what they want
that's what they're asking for is like a
sprinkle chocolate doughnut it's our job
to cook the doughnuts and keep the kid
on okay okay keep the kitchen weak so
you want to test the doughnuts keep
tapping the doughnuts and then when
they're done they're to put them over
just half the doughnut they're done
they're burning to have to doughnut -
yup put it over there all right now I
got to put some chocolate sauce on there
you don't hit some coconut sprinkles for
that guy coconut sprinkles for that guy
you could just tap the coconut you tap
the coconut sprinkles yeah all right now
give that guy that doughnut press the
press leave which guy he doesn't want
they don't just have to don't it'll go
to the right guy oh it automatically
goes to the right guy what skill is that
but you got to keep tapping the
doughnuts to keep them keep the kitchen
movie okay okay yeah keep okay yep
doughnut pee tap the pink doughnut there
I got it all right yeah give the guy the
milkshake there all right your doughnuts
are burnin all right give that now you
want to put the pink sauce on the other
doughnut why up this guy is doing weight
kind of try that try new they don't
observe old until you got to do the pink
sauce and the doughnuts there you go yes
yes there we go there we go all right
now that you know chocolate can I say
something yes there's not enough people
working here for the kind of business
look at this jerk burn something burn
something he knows I burned something
he knows I burned something take over
all right see that oh you tap it twice
to toss it away so you look look at that
look at this so you look game there we
go see you just got it's all about donut
management you know you just gotta gotta
keep it go and keep the keep the kitchen
move in there we go it's gay akshay
one of maybe six reasons why the
American Empire is in decline that's
right never got the coconut sprinkles
look at this see see it's just like it's
all about tapping it's all about you
just got to keep that baby going I think
I could probably run a donut shop right
there's an elf for giving the donut at
the elf 3 dish combo look at that you're
there's aunt you're an empty person
inside there's nothing inside you that's
an empty shell this is true all right
you know it's not a good game when I'm
actually being distracted by a bottle of
water it's sitting on the floor I saw
this and I was looking at it like huh
that bottle doesn't have
I wonder what kind of bottled water it
is it looks like it hasn't had no one
had it yet it seems to be room
temperature that's what I'm thinking
about while you make it a nut killing it
over here look at this thing the snowman
guy got this stuff so this is for
children yeah yeah I mean yeah it's
there we go I'm a winner
look at that you yes it just said I'm a
winner you're just your life was just
affirmed that's by an offensive
stereotype that's right exactly
I'm a winner I thank you by the way for
the jacket the the Christmas gift that
we all got thank you for that jacket did
you pick that pick that I did actually
gave me a bunch of options for the
Christmas jacket and I saw that bomber
with a hood yeah and I liked it yeah I
said there's only one problem
it doesn't say Conan and when people
walk around and that's the kind of a
hole I am when I give a gift it has my
name's Stan when I give my you know my
mother
a bouquet of flowers it spells out watch
Conan on TBS yeah see there it is right
there you can be that's a nice bomber
jacket right there you can't really see
you'd have to have someone model it yeah
the best model did earlier there okay
got it got it cool that zip around the
bicep there just got these cool pockets
yeah you can keep all your cool stuff
that's right it's pretty great um how
long have you been doing how many games
you playing uh we're playing all these
games okay it's amazing
yeah we're in it's amazing what does
that mean it's amazing that there's this
many awesome games on the Google Play
Store everybody Kona noticed me I have
Tito's tattoos for Heisenberg do you
want to see you want to see one other
game no okay all right all right well
thank you Happy Happy Holidays to the
chat us happy holidays everybody
why do you talk to me like I'm an old
geezer nursing home well you're wearing
that hat like an old man the holidays
are you gonna say it grab get you mush
mush hey someone said they don't like my
hat you're crazy
this is that look at all the stick I can
do with this hat hello golf net Oh
or we could I'll get a bank loan I'll
Drive you Bronx I got a cab it's 1948
look at this this guy ever even know
that guy does the hip hop kind of it was
not hip hop okay I don't know where you
were going again this I'll see you guys
later bye everybody he was doing this
and thank you for your mostly calm
positive comments and you know okay so
uh all right guys that's it for us
next up is our coworkers Kelly and
Kramer hopefully they can find Allison
hi team cocoa Google followers you I'm
Kelly I'm Kramer Kramer all right yeah
yeah I'm great
you are gonna play I'm gonna play first
you're gonna play five nights at freddys
okay wait we have to stare at ourselves
in this video the whole time what do we
do here scream I what do you do I'm
Kelly and I helped what you do produce
yeah I'm guest interview segments it's a
lot of research and making sure conan
doesn't say the wrong thing and go to
celebrities and say oh my god you have
five kids and they're like what no I
have no kids so stuff like that so you
you're like responsible for the blue
card that come in rings yes and so then
kind of like cultivating the
conversation with the celebrities and
figuring that kind of stuff out so I
work with a segment producer Frank
smiley who's been with Conan since day
one 1993
and he produces the segment and I kind
of him just help him out and make sure
he has everything he needs and all the
different departments have the clips and
the pictures and whatever they need to
produce the segment right some of you
know me I do mostly the field production
stuff a lot of the remotes a lot of the
commercial parodies that we do and I've
been here a while and do ya creamer what
have you been here like 20 years 10 10
Paul shout-out to you thanks says he
he's my guy this chat down here you can
see yeah I see it okay so what do you do
the like what's what's your job j22
likes my shoes they're great yeah how
did you even see your shoes tell me when
I walked in oh they're just that great
oh there you go that's why cuz you're
doing like that little the cool guy says
the cool guy said yeah that's it but you
still haven't gone into like what you do
for work no so it'sit's a lot of it's
coordinating the remote coordinating the
commercial parodies I shot something a
couple weeks ago called hindsight
Financial which was a commercial parody
we did about a financial institution
that tells you all of the investments
you could have made I recently got back
from Haiti with everybody yeah so it's
cool it was really cool actually if you
haven't seen the Haiti episode you
really should because it's one of the
favorite things I've ever done on this
show
the peanut gallery is me and Kramer used
to sit next to each other we were
cubicle buddies were cubicle buddies and
then we got separated you had to move
one cubicle way so now we don't know as
much as we use I know it hurts me every
day but your phone
truly rings all day long yeah like
non-stop I take a lot of coal I used to
sneak over and like turn the volume down
that's really fun cuz I was like so loud
and then you come back you turn it up I
feel like you've invaded my personal
space and I understand that's fine with
me
okay what's good I wanna see you play
five nights at Freddy's
because I know a little bit about this
game okay Help Wanted Freddy fazbear's
pizza so this is a horror game we're
gonna start to play here it says
celebrate celebrate I'm ready I'm
excited I don't understand oh there we
go okay isn't there like a tutorial we
can watch first or something I think you
should trial by fire
and so these are like security cameras
technical difficulties
no I think this is great so you're
looking at these security they're
looking at these security cameras and
you're keeping watching some ones that
look hi Kelly 2020 alright so let's
start playing this game I heard Conan
interns make so much I was a Conan an
intern way back in the day and you are
correct we make so much valuable life
experience it's really wonderful very
rich fulfilling all right so it looks
like we've got like some sort of
security camera right but you see every
time you check a camera you lose power
so you have to be
you have to be careful about but what am
I looking for Kramer you're looking for
like bad guys you're looking for
intruders for malfeasance well I don't
see any on this one you say losing power
check a different camera and then you
can see you've got right there but what
do I do if I even see someone let's go
you can turn on the light camera I'm not
as technologically as man advanced as
you are what's the goal what are we
looking for goes to the trouble place to
make sure nothing bad happens what do
these people want that's a really good
question
what
so 150 percent we've gotten nothing done
sounds like maybe for you yeah well I'm
just very efficient hi Kramer I think
you handed me the Conan pop at the end
of the show at SDCC very possible Johnny
probably we at comic-con it's such a
crazy mess and there's so much work to
be done that we all try and jump in
wherever we can we all help as much as
possible one of those things is given
everybody think what someone said you're
so cruel for making Kelly play this
without any background knowledge yeah
you are guys Kramer knew you did this
I'm perfect you gotta keep playing that
you have to experience the game so what
like what's happening there's a bathroom
the only have 19 percent powerless
someone said r.i.p kelly first why so
many women i illumination is scared
someone said Kramer model dem shoes son
I know people love shoes and then
someone on YouTube said are they
monitoring twitch more the answer is no
it's just where I had my eyes focus it's
just so it's happening I love you
YouTube okay at 1% and I've gotten
nowhere what are you now on fear now the
power zone okay well you did this on
purpose how ours not winning it Oh
what's happening you literally not but
what's that Oh turn on the way close the
door I don't know how to turn the light
on
[Music]
womp-womp well yeah that's what I do and
I'm like anxious that working like first
night nice and now we're back at the
beginning so why don't you show me what
oh the phone's ringing maybe she
answered the phone
so do you know what's going on or do you
not read just like planing me laughs
around yeah pretty much
I've actually never played five nights
at four wait
so I noticed haze all the big ones
[Music]
okay let's see first in an introductory
greeting from the company
okay what's he seeing anything relevant
then ha to have your own place for kids
and grown-ups alike
[Music]
that's where Tina is not responsible for
damage to property or impertinent
here's a tip dump them thanks fingers to
summary this game is for spooky do you
just have to be on the right camera the
exact right time to see what goes wrong
see like it's just a poster I'm Tovar
let's so you just want to be switching
around and then you you happen to get
yeah if you see if they're if they're
coming through you have to close the
door
you have to see if they're coming
through the left or the right and if
they are
you have to close the doors but every
time you use the light or the door you
use power that's why you're supposed to
be strategic about what you're asking
when I said Kelly with an eye I meant
kil ly and no I meant Kelo hi guys how
could you even think Oh someone said
love your remotes creamer
how can you guys but they want to talk
about we can't do anything for you I
don't know anything I wish I wish we had
the power to make those sorts of
decisions right now but it's also like
someone was laughing their buns off or a
mesh or added that almost scared
poopless I don't know what that bad
Kelly do you think at least they spelled
my name right hi this okay I just wish
someone in the comments would tell us
how to play this game yeah you guys
aren't being very cool Mike give us a
hint on what we're supposed to do
because we've just been in this office
building for like 10 minutes doing
nothing it's 3 a.m. now like this is our
first night on the job we've made no
progress and it's it's getting a
stressful it is we've opened the door
we've closed the door we turn the light
on turn the light off what else is there
what are we looking for what if it's
supposed to represent the human
condition I don't know that's swage we
aren't even playing the game that's
right we're not I it's I never played it
and I just know what happens because
that's the kind of guy I am
Oh what do you mean by that can you
elaborate no I will not it's for you to
find out
you think this game would be I'm waiting
for like a jump-scare I'm waiting to
throw the tablet down camera disable
uh-oh maybe they're coming from the
right side
Oh Oh is let me happen look there's that
that guy's standing in the that that
that guy that one
yeah I don't think he should be there
wait a green one he's kind of got a
menacing look in his eye whatever get
him I don't think you can I think all
you can do is close the door powers out
[Music]
wait someone said tip keep your eyes on
security cameras but not too much keep
doors closed keep the doors closed then
nothing else happens when does something
exciting happen answer the phone
[Music]
right
now see it answers but screamer a lot of
people are asking if Conan's still
chokes you for sexual pleasure yes I've
seen it happen that makes you a 30
weight closing the doors loses power
don't keep the doors closed oh I see
right you can't win if you keep them
shut you have to open them right and if
the power runs out then already comes
[Applause]
but we run up our toys and Freddie still
over kid
yeah
or someone on your camera $0.00 ignore
line
I'm out of my mouth
and on a perfect pirate
no I'm gonna figure this game out and in
the meanwhile you can talk about how you
got hired at Conant
thank you I got hired at MBC in 2009 as
an intern
a gloriously unpaid intern it was a
really great experience and then I just
sort of hung around long enough until
they started paying me and then I got
hired as a PA in 2009 and sorry 2010 at
this show and sort of kept doing more
and more stuff until I was in charge of
some stuff which is great and very big
and big on purpose how did you need your
job
I was also an intern and I started
covering a desk one day they just needed
someone to cover her a desk and then I
was basically like this is my job now
yeah that's how it works and I'm not
leaving and I'm staying here and that
was four years ago
so nobody yeah it's true because that's
how a lot of opportunities show up in
this industry is the timing is right and
you show up in a really good job and
someone said things get more active as
you go along
creddies freddie is that you Kelly wants
to meet Fred I want to meet you come out
let's hang out we're cool us Eisenberg's
as Kramer started working when I was six
and that makes me so sad my own
mortality stick your foot in the door
how we ball girl teach us did I pass out
[Music]
if you don't check on that guy funky
music Roberto asks if he can work for
American television if he's from abroad
and the answer is yes but it's Oh
Freddie got us where from where oh this
is not cool game over
why do you know how to play this game
Kramer because I don't know everything
isn't there like isn't there like a
button on here where I can get some more
information we could buy a Freddy
plushie guys is the credit card attached
oh yes yes you can if you want
[Music]
let's try dr. George you want to try one
more time and then go to contre jour
yeah let's try it
I mean I don't know what else we're
gonna do what more what answers by
itself
Kelly answer the phone Kelly's driving
it's the same thing this guy says
nothing it's just like every phone call
I've ever had honestly what were you
doing before you got here before I got
to Freddie before I got we got to work
her oh I just came from my friend's
pizza birthday party um happy birthday
mica waited great yeah my god happy
birthday she's not watching she's no no
she is watching oh she is yeah I was I
didn't tune in yeah they would support
their friend even though it's her
birthday
yeah we had a great time we eat so much
pizza it was really fun
Weavile girl says it's honestly a super
frustrating game you know what you were
weevil girls giving us the best
information we've gotten all night tell
us more and then someone says it's a bad
game for the tablet which I agree I feel
like there's not a lot you can do here
but you know it's still a good game
Stallone someone said don't listen to
the guy on the phone he's trying to get
you killed
what that's a quiet spoilers this guy
says hi Kramer greetings from India I
love the look on remotes I'm impressed
how you remain so common even when
coming chassis I am NOT the master of
course you want to point that one out
Kramer hell is like a complimentary of
you oh that's the one comment hari Kelly
is the master of stay sane calm under
pressure absolutely not
that's disagree you are also the
sassiest package I just speak
it's true that's all you do is speak the
truth what do you think about that bunny
I know that's scary he's coming to get
us
he's not moving he looks like he's on
crutches like are you okay what happened
I think those are just the backs of
chairs cause he's gone now so ezel I
check one statement one seat
[Music]
no that's a died the other one was a
bunny this is I love the setup and the
tablet and everything but like this game
like what do you want from me tell me
what to do I don't understand why
Freddie to just like come out so I can
just like you want them but that you
lose it Freddie comes out that's he gets
oh so if we just sit here and do nothing
then we'll win no because we just lost
twice already really no weed you don't
know how to play I don't we quit the
first time and then we made it one night
and then we died and like do you just
always make it through the first night
maybe that's what happens
I don't know there's nothing it's like I
think we move on I feel like I'm in like
a basement of a warehouse like where Oh
close the door that was that bunny on
crutches yeah he was coming to get us
can we open this to say power
and it made like four annoys
Oh someone said me and Mike have the
same birthday happy birthday cue em
Heisenberg
night two is where the game starts
someone fed so if we can just hold out
through night one did it exam nice see
the kids are cheering it's great on our
back yes
the game's gonna start they said oh
great we're back in the same room the
phone's ringing again the phone great
this is half your job at Conan is the
answer it's true those two this new one
there now
we made it today dude congrats Congrats
but can we make it tonight sweet well
girls been with us through it all like
honestly she's our homie tell us more
hard liquor
do we need some
I don't know I don't trust this guy on
the phone I feel like he's trying to get
us killed
right yeah but he's got that kind of
voice like oh wait just a male voice
yeah don't trust it not that would be in
any danger
someone said oh my gosh creamer Kelly do
you know what's in the suits no we don't
you lie tell us is it nothing
someone said pizza party for making it
to the second night heck yeah we'd love
to have another pizza party I feel like
this game is just sit here and don't
touch anything and then like maybe
you'll survive yet another metaphor for
life okay where everyone wants to know
what's in your cup unfortunately I think
yes seltzer water and warm milk yeah
nothing interesting no it's just water
but the cool Conan Cup because I'm a
responsible person someone said there's
bodies of dead children in the suits
what can we see it spice this up come on
who's Alison no it's why did the light
not work a second ago
who don't know that you go yeah there's
noises we didn't make it he got us you
got it but at least we made it tonight -
I think that's an impressive feat in and
of itself even if Freddie comes though
how would we kill him like I don't know
no I don't think the idea is vengeance
it's just to be alive um like boring I
wanna like I want some action what's the
other game line here is it this one I
forget the name of it it's this one
country joy oh yeah contre jour this one
er we were really excited about it
memorize a lot about it
did you know I just obviously said I
don't remember the name someone said I
think Kramer is drinking vodka but
doesn't want to get fired I promise you
he's not cool enough to be drinking
vodka right now oh not what's happening
in my tablet right hurts
[Music]
it's so fun with these comments don't
open that [ __ ] this one seems like nice
nice and sweet and pleasant not add your
finger - oh it's like it's like
landscaping we just like move these
around it's like being Bobby from Queer
Eye for this for the straight guy on
Netflix just like is that just coke
right
yeah Bobby from queer ID you just like
decide what's gonna be best for this
little guy who like we he needs our help
I think that's to help him and like
revamp his life like I feel like he
could use a nice blazer I think he just
had to get to the light oh yeah that was
probably it I mean it's probably some
cosmic I'll get to that later but you
can collect as many lights as you can
from the power
[Music]
the music really nice and this is like
relaxing Zima guys
what do you mean tear you someone said
maybe I'm drinking zina and then I might
not be cool enough to be drinking vodka
but I'm definitely cooler than drinking
Zima
[Music]
get yeah there you go
and then you just roll down to the light
follow the light
yeah but anything good happen good job
oh you didn't know I got only two out of
three
Thanks oh what's that uh more milk
no you know you want try again to get
all fours move on
someone said Kramer's drinking capri-sun
action that sounds like a great idea the
peanut gallery agrees hold it tentacle -
that was cool Oh maybe you have to drop
it though release when it's on the right
side this is this is great I like this
little one-eyed guy better than Freddy
Freddy was fun - the name of this game
is contra juror geek that did what Chad
am i reading no clue
twitch is on the that's what Jim that's
YouTube Kelly is very honest but someone
said that conch is comfortable it is
comfortable this game is really fun it
seems like a good game to like play at
work you keep going yeah is did you play
a lot of games at work going
you know know do you know but you know
which games are good to play it work
well this just seems like it would be
maybe unassuming like look like you're
swiping through emails I'm like trying
to get a lot of work done like oh but
really you're just like playing this
little eyeball thing right but drop it
[Music]
[Music]
perfect perfect score creamer good job
this one's fun do you want to try to
level sure come on you keep saying how
fun it is plus now I want to read the
chat
Alex fire shoutout for you YouTube how
do you think I get it through so
straight the stripes don't stretch
oh so you you've got a like angle it so
you can look on this one it's got to go
it's gonna make like an arc and then
it'll hit the stripy thing and go into
the an arc around to the right yeah so
see well though see how all those lights
are like that I think you have to get it
so he falls in such a way to hit the
stripy one or he'll just die show me how
it's done
stripes don't stretch but you can turn a
movie you can sway the stripe but I type
my timings on you I try no we're still
going I'm bad I thought I wasn't good
you get better at things by trying okay
thanks I was positive motivation for me
we're all positive here namaste
how are the two are there no god but I
keep acting like there is no that's it
good that's good that's intuitive
where is sona who knows that's a good
question
grandma you can tell everyone about that
one time you went to Vegas was so not
ours fine oh it was like no okay
oh you me oh my god no yeah what I do
not count it's a I can edit the story
for but then you have to share Vegas
story of your own I've never been to
Vegas what I do not that ISM I'm from
Michigan we don't really go there so in
like Atlantic City never but I don't
know I'm too little montreal montreal
yeah I'm gonna tell the Vegas story I'm
gonna play I want you to tell the Vegas
Vegas Joy's fun so in like 2011 Sona had
wanted to go see Arcade Fire in Las
Vegas with a couple people and we all
decided that's a great idea why not go
see Arcade Fire they're a good band and
it was Thursday night and we're like
well we'll just leave the show and we'll
fly to Vegas and go to see the show and
then come back but we decided we show
what's it called isn't that called a
thing like rounded round about a u-turn
are you ten so we did a u-turn in Vegas
we decided we're not gonna get a hotel
room just after the show we're gonna
wander the strip until our flight left
back for LA at like 6:00 the next
morning which sounded like an amazing
idea at the time because we were young
and reckless and Arcade Fire was gonna
be a great show when there were like
four of us and whatever it's gonna be
cool so we go we land in Vegas the first
thing we do is get in like a karaoke
match with the cab driver on the way of
the Hard Rock which was great he was
clearly hitting on Sona really hard and
it was super awkward we get to the show
we enjoy the show
walk out great yeah we're full of energy
we walk into like Caesars Palace
or drinking and having fun and gambling
it's like 2:00 3:00 in the morning we're
kind of fading we'd worked all day we'd
been up since like you know seven or
eight that morning we'd see the show
we're starting to fade were like crap we
don't have anywhere to go
[Laughter]
[Music]
no I want to see what I don't understand
how you get it to show you it wants to
do it you turn like your biggest advice
so you got to get this to like swing a
little me and I was swinging it hard but
I ball goes right through it so you got
it you got to modify the terrain so that
the timing is right so he gets it right
when it's like you can do it you know
the right track even if you swing this
up though he still goes right through it
so no he's like a ghost no I think he's
probably just got to hit it like in the
right come on attach the string to the
black thing someone said so like made me
first
you know like that that's way easier
than I thought oh my god they were right
yeah I thought he had to like thank you
geek that dude buddy it's like cool did
you do anyway we're in Vegas getting
drunk having a great time it's like 2:00
3:00 in the morning and we walk by this
club in Vegas in the Caesars Palace
called Cleopatra's barge which looks
like a big ship it's ridiculous and this
is where the night takes a turn a turn
for the worse we were all fading we were
all not having a good time or like crap
we should have gotten a hotel room it's
3:00 in the morning we have to go to
work tomorrow
out of Cleopatra's barge what walks a
woman beer beer wedding dress pregnant
double fisting the beers pregnant
assault can all be wedding dress that's
about the time I decide I'm gonna go
take a nap in front of the bathrooms at
Caesar's Palace and I lay down for like
15 minutes and I don't know what
happened then the next thing I do know
is we're in the Bellagio maybe somewhere
we're getting breakfast when that's my
watch telling me it's bedtime because
I'm an adult who's responsible you gotta
try it again you can't just do good
enough yeah anyway the nice man we got
the next time they can see it on the you
see how it's behind us on the oh yeah
beer ski 180 is right we're almost to 12
hours that is crazy twelve hours what do
you think I got me stuck
so inside Kramer after hearing your
story understand why Conan feels the
need to choke you oh I get it too you
don't wanted me to tell this story I
don't have more of a synopsis you're
booting it's okay bud
but getting patronized losing at this
game what's your suggestion for right
here um hook it hook it to that hook
that to the eyeball and then yeah yeah
and then get that and then hook it again
to get the other on
you try
Brenda wants me to finish this Rory the
end of the story is we end up we get to
Las Vegas
there's no respect coming from any part
of the story is they get to the Vegas
Airport and they have to like sleep or
some things and then they came straight
to work you say welcome right but I'll
sleep in front of the closed tsa for 30
minutes on the floor of the Vegas
Airport came back to LA had an intern
pick us up from the airport came to work
the abused and interns dude is no the
intern for that particular intern got
paid for their mileage yeah and then
that day was my birthday so the end of
the u-turn was an office birthday party
and Ultimo cupcakes in the conference
room it was a cake and último made the
cake with the Starbucks logo but instead
of the Starbucks logo it was my
silhouette with my long hair mm-hmm no I
am that sounds like fun I just I'm
trying to concentrate on getting this
little black eyeball year this whole
thing was a mistake to come to okay no
don't say that we just kidding we got
killed by Freddie a couple vibrating a
couple times just getting it from all
angles
everybody's
[Music]
no you a lot of people are really
curious about Conan beating you up yeah
it happens it's physical assault yeah
everyone finds funny someone just said
Kelly can have a shout-out from you but
I um can't see your name anymore and
disappeared sorry
shout out to that person shut up to that
person
someone said Cramer's the plot to
hangover part 4 you should write that Oh
pitch it pitch it keeping me in Zach
Galifianakis so much that creamer you
ain't the greatest storyteller I thought
you did a great job Cramer myself I mean
the story is obviously better when you
know me and I can tell the story and not
get just no good story no I think it's
really good the idea of a u-turn it
sounds like so much fun would it be a
good anecdote for Frank to produce to
put on the show
I think yet that if what's your anecdote
if you get booked on the show it let's
say you become really famous the time
you get booked on the show but like
let's say you did what would be what
would be the stories you tell your
guests
my first guest lot two segments this is
such a crazy question like what a wild
world we live in
I'm on Conan like I feel bad it listen
it do you know many interns have come
through Conan and then became really
famous like 300 just got caught in a fly
trap what you for try this all right but
I'm gonna try this level and you have to
explain what your anecdote would be if
you were booked on the show what are the
questions on the blue card what I don't
know it depends what I'm promoting with
what would you want to be on for I don't
know who knows what life would throw at
me you know it's crazy
yeah but like just pick something like
let's say you're a famous actress I'm
not gonna be a famous actress clearly
for my performance on this live stream
Wow
don't you can you can call me bad and
make fun of me but don't make fun of
yourself that's not cool
you're great and everyone should feel
good about themselves someone said can I
be an intern maybe if you apply and get
hired that's how it works I'd beat it
oh my gosh good job because I kept
getting caught in the flytrap you got to
do that one all right but you haven't
told your anecdote
I don't have one Kramer that's why I
know just talk about what was Kelly
Smith liking at Michigan State someone
said it's Kelly's real name Debbie no go
green away yeah all right so talk about
college life did go to Michigan State
University it's great school it's a
great time and that's it someone's at RB
Plaza worked for Conan was she an intern
I'm not sure I know John Krasinski and
John Krasinski Mindy Kaling Ellie Kemper
Angela Kinsey basically they were all
interns I'm not sure oh you know what it
is Aubrey Plaza was an NBC page who we
used to give tours of our conan's old
studio but she was never an intern
specifically at Conan but someone said I
have straight season don't want to move
too late can I be an intern I think you
part of the requirements you have just
like no one cares about your C's we're
fine with that but just locate like
geographically just don't think it would
work out honestly though a lot of it is
your work ethic not necessarily your
grade point average if you can get in
the door and then prove yourself that
means a lot but you have to be able to
get in the door
I think he's stuck so once I Kelly
should just tell Kramer's Vegas story is
her anecdote yeah one time he in Sona
went to Vegas we did the u-turn it was
crazy
u-turn Calif I was ever my pageant barge
getting hit on by this really annoying
guy in the restaurant who took his
wedding ring off and then talked about
how much he didn't want to pay out a
life insurance claim good times yeah now
that I keep going on these cactus things
someone named Alexis said give her a
shout-out highlight says Kelly but they
spelled your name like really wrong okay
I'm gonna get this this is it crazy
little moldy pizza asked what we do at
Team Coco on a daily basis a typical day
for me depends a lot on what kind of
pre-tape comedy is coming down the
pipeline when me and Kramer used to sit
next to each other we shove for time a
lot roots lay on the floor when we were
tired there's a dog here guys um and
then sometimes we'd get coffee and then
sometimes you'd eat breakfast and work
we also for time I do miss floor time
that floor is floor time is just like
when you're really tired at work and you
just go time to lay on the floor yeah
you just gotta take some you time just
got to relax a little bit what kind what
kind of dog is running around guys
it's a puggle oh I got can we see the
dog I think the dog would be up in one
of the next segments if you stay up
the dog is is sitting on the couch alone
for the next two hours just to and
because it's gonna be so much more
entertaining
it's a puggle it's really cute don't
sell us short drink your drink
I'm trying I am and then you got a zoo
Alison we don't know Alison is tell us
that Jordan shlonsky story you have a
shlonsky story um not really
he is every bit the person you think he
is
yeah that's the create that's the
shlonsky story is that what you've seen
on TV is not an act it's really who he
is
oh you can use multi-touch I see it's
trying to give us a hand
reading is reading his power and being
what that guys here we are we're done
we're wrapping this up the top of the
hour the top of the hour and we're gonna
go check in with our chicken boss
the Maryland shelf O'Brien midnight is a
creepy I win all kinds of ghouls and
goblins
come out to pay wish I had fought a
little bit about this song before I
started
[Music]
all right so now you started reading it
say it now we're gonna check out a video
of Conan at the YouTube space in New
York which is actually a piece I worked
on good for you we are at YouTube
headquarters here in Chelsea very cool
space and this is Tom small I don't work
Sarah nice to see you how are you great
you had this VR Department is that
correct yeah I had a VR for the YouTube
spaces okay VR is virtual reality I
don't want to blow your mind with my
high tech talk but virtual reality is
really the future I think so I think it
can help us in many many ways but also I
think we should go carefully
yes that's like when you get married
yeah maybe in the future we'll get
virtual married yeah and then on
virtually fight or virtually have her
say how come you're always worrying
about your show and on our children
Birchwood say hey that's none of your
business this show pays for everything
and then she virtually says you know
what's the name Conan anyway I never
liked that name good I'm saying
but I am very interested in what this
means for pornography I'm thinking of it
- I took off all my clothes and I get
into a cube and then various lotions and
gels are injected into the cube sensors
are put on my body and I have incredible
erotic experiences that take me to new
heights and then I get out of the cube
four five years later we are now in the
VR lab that's right it's the latest in
technology clearly which involves I
think just green paper
we've now achieved what Weather
Channel's figured out over 40 years ago
we try to be ahead of it okay here we go
goggles okay I just hit the trigger and
move your hand through space how do I
start with a whole fresh view okay the
spin spin it around with your thumb
until you see the tool palette with the
trashcan down on the bottom okay now
you're starting fresh would you like to
go to outer space oh man look at this
well I'm trying but only you can see it
I know because I am the chosen one
this is going to put the marijuana
industry out of business
Harrison feels all the time tell you
what if you want to destroy the plant no
I just want to fondle it okay again it's
all gonna go towards porn you know that
look I'm just rubbing up against the
planet NOW caressing it I'll see you
later
hello human welcome to an accurate
simulation of obvious worker cool like a
red velvet donut I taste nothing we got
to work on that guy a little bit of
creamer this is actually how I behave at
the office clean this up I want to make
a Xerox copy of the stapler
we're gonna get to packing right into
the brain what's this incredible in the
future I'm still an [ __ ] thank you
look this is an accurate simulation of
gourmet chef as this gluten-free because
if it isn't I'm gonna have virtual
diarrhea I don't think they'll take it
like that they're not gonna take it like
that what's wrong with that no you know
that's what my mother served me for most
of my childhood corn on the cob on a
piece of toast let's see if the way to
work they should go hit a bell yeah the
Bell will only have gear if they're
gonna be happy with it oh so the waiter
doesn't like what I've made this is the
chef kind of call the shots okay some
cheese how's that is that a sandwich
it's a cheese sandwich
there's the sandwich here this sucks
hell am i trapped in what you just
staring at me
this should be more pornographic that's
for the future is gooder Stan I should
be getting it on in this kitchen see
this oil
I should be putting this on my body get
that oil down there you can take the old
Johnson if you know what I mean you know
I'm right that's why you have no answer
I don't want to work anymore I want to
have some fun what's next let's take him
to the gym oh my god the hell is this
guy this is your trainer yeah this is my
trainer he's lift-away nyan I'm just
looking at him I'm just experiencing the
sadness in his eyes it's guy had a
horrible childhood I don't know what
they did to you in the gulag Wow but my
apologies with ugly Joe's picture there
the yellow picture in a second oh oh my
god I can't I can't fight this guy you
look terrible you shouldn't be fighting
you should be back in the iron lung
hi good to see you
hey you're checking me out judging by
your shorts I don't know if we're gonna
fight or drink margaritas you have a
spot back here and you should definitely
have a dermatologist look at
that was incredible you again you
trained me and then I knocked out that
champion and I ain't now I'm the champ
so I just came here to see your face
register excitement and joy this is very
familiar to me had guys like you in the
audience
nothing I say gets a chuckle I'm gonna
hear a joke I had a German girlfriend
and she liked to write my sexual
performance on a scale of 1 to 10 I
tried anal one night I thought I was
doing pretty well because she was
shouting nein nein do the ideas 19 means
no so that's why that's funny
yes I know someone hurt you a long time
ago like the wall it's time to let that
wall down I can take us back to the
kitchen when there's oil there I can see
you're thinking about it
if you're interested in having sex with
me blink once
[Applause]
here Thanks
my followers we're back we're back we're
here
we just had it's such a good time a lot
of money Freddie Highmore it's called
five nights at freddy's five nights at
freddy's that was a good one it was like
lots of anticipation lots of who knows
what's gonna happen know what's gonna
happen we did no idea and then we play
truly clueless contra jerk contre jour
contre jour and say and that was really
fun too that's what it's all I keep
saying it's a lot like cut the rope
which was the game I really enjoyed I
remember cut the rope I was like how
like that right yeah yeah yeah the same
sort of physics like the perfect timing
you have to get to go so we're just
changing over the stream feeds guys the
they're posting links make sure you
switch over some technical things I was
explaining there's a dog it's sneezing
his name's Jake right Jake the Pug all
yes
switching over this streaming site
whatever that means is Blake coming back
probably I mean like he's not a gone
away forever